Rồi các bạn, tuần trước chúng ta đang
dừng lại ở cái đoạn mà chúng ta
chúng ta làm gì nhở? [hắng giọng] Chúng
ta xây dựng cái một cái mô hình
classification dành cho dành cho cái bộ
về job đúng không? Chúng ta đã thực hiện
một cái bước tối ưu là gì? là chúng ta
thêm vào hai cái tham số là min df với
cả max df vào cái bước tf idf vectorizer
này là cái bước để chúng ta làm sao
chúng ta có thể giảm bớt cái số lượng số
lượng token được tạo ra cho cái phần job
description tại vì chúng ta biết là phần
lớn các cái feature tạo ra ở cái bước
reposing đấy phần lớn nó đến từ cái ông
số 3 này đúng không thì các bạn thấy là
lúc trước khi mà chúng ta áp dụng min
với maf này ấy chúng ta có tổng cộng là
840 48000
nghìn cái feature đúng không? Và phần
lớn chúng là đến từ cái cột job
description đúng không? Phần lớn chúng
đến từ cái cột này.
Thế nhưng mà sau khi chúng ta áp dụng
min df mdsf chúng ta thấy là cái
performance nó tốt hơn rất là nhiều đúng
không? Và các bạn thấy là cái kết quả nó
cũng kết quả đây là kết quả của lần gì
nh mình chạ lại thử nhá. Mình không nhớ
rõ lắm là đấy. Kết quả lúc trước hay là
sau khi chúng ta áp dụng min max df.
Hình như đây là lúc a
trước hay sau ấy nhỉ? Hình như đây là
trước thì phải. Nếu mình nhớ nếu mình
nhớ không nhầm thì đây là trước. Ừ hình
như là trước. Tức là khi mà mình vẫn
đang dùng toàn bộ feature dùng toàn bộ
chỗ này đúng không? Thì nó ra kết quả
như này. Hình như là sau khi dùng xong
ông này lên 73, ông này lên bảy mấy đứ
thì phải. Chờ chạy lại nhá. Chạy lại
nhá. Đúng không? Ở đây mình đang dùng
mdf này đúng không? mình giảm bớt mình
lọc bớt những cái những cái token nào mà
trong cái cột description này nó xuất
hiện ít quá hoặc nhiều quá đúng không?
Ít quá nó cũng nó cũng không có nhiều
giá trị mà nhiều quá nó cũng không có
nhiều giá trị đúng không? Ông nào xuất
hiện dưới 1% tổng số lượng document hoặc
là trên 99% tôi loại bỏ bớt chúng đi
được chưa? Nó sẽ áp dụng cho cả unigram
và by tất nhiên tôi chỉ áp dụng cho cột
này thôi. Được chưa?
Rồi này đúng không? chúng lại xử lý tất
nhiên giảm bớt đi nhưng mà số lượng
feature nó vẫn còn rất là nhiều đúng
không? Nó còn tiếng này feature và chúng
ta dùng một cái mô hình khá là lớn chúng
ta dùng chúng ta dùng dùng random fres
mô hình rất là lớn thì nó tất nhiên nó
sẽ lâu nhưng mà nó sẽ nhanh hơn. À đây
là lần này lần đầu này mình chạy này nó
lâu tại vì tại vì đây là lần đầu mình
chạy cái project này trong hôm nay bình
thường máy mình cứ khở đập lại nó sẽ
chạy hơi lâu một chút. Đ các bạn nhìn
này kết quả đây này được chưa? Lúc đó 68
lên được 73 rồi được chưa? 70 lên được
75 rồi đúng không? 64 lên được 71 rồi.
Thế các bạn thấy không? Chúng ta chỉ
thêm mỗi một cái đoạn này chúng ta lọc
bớt số lượng feature đi mà các bạn thấy
là cái mô hình của mình nó vừa tốt hơn,
tức là nó vừa nhỏ hơn, nhẹ hơn, chạy
nhanh hơn, kết quả còn tốt hơn nữa, đúng
không? Quả nó còn tốt hơn nữa. Thì đây
là những gì mà chúng ta đang dừng lại ở
cái bước của tuần trước đúng không?
Chúng ta đang dừng lại ở ở cái chỗ như
này.
Thế thì
đấy là một bước chúng ta lọc đúng không?
Chúng ta lọc bớt cái feature dư thừa của
cái cột job description này. Được chưa?
Thế nhưng mà đấy nó mới chỉ ở một bước
thôi đúng không? Tuy rằng cái cột job
description này là cái cột nó chiếm đa
số lượng feature nhưng mà nó không phải
là duy nhất. Bốn ông kia hoàn toàn cũng
có khả năng là chúng nó sẽ contribute,
chúng nó sẽ đóng góp những cái feature
mà chả mấy quan trọng đúng không? Bốn
ông này cũng hoàn toàn có thể có khả
năng nó là nó nó đóng góp những cái
feature nó chả quan trọng gì cả đúng
không? Thì bây giờ lọc ở trên này là một
bước rồi. Nhưng ở dưới này chúng ta cũng
sẽ nên thực hiện lọc thêm một lần nữa.
Thể hiện lọc thêm một lần nữa. Thì chúng
ta sẽ có một cái bước chèn mặt giữa này.
Tức là gì? Tức là cái số lượng feature
của chúng ta trước khi chúng ta đưa vào
cho mô hình chúng ta sẽ lọc bớt những
cái feature mà ít quan trọng đi. Thế thì
làm sao để lọc được như vậy? Thì bây giờ
để lọc được như vậy ấy chúng ta sẽ có
một cái phần liên quan đến trong sơn nó
có một cái gọi là selectb.
Cái này nó là một cái nó là một cái
class rất là hữu ích trong việc nó giúp
chúng ta lọc bớt các cái feature nó ít
quan trọng đi. Các bạn tưởng tượng này,
cái này nó dùng rất là đơn giản thôi.
Tức là gì? Tức là nó sẽ lấy cái input
đầu vào là X với cả Y. X là đầu vào và Y
là đầu ra. Đấy, được chưa? Và nó sẽ giúp
chúng ta tính điểm. Tính điểm cái gì? Nó
sẽ giúp chúng ta tính điểm của từng cái
feature. Nó tính điểm bằng cách nào? Nó
tính điểm bằng đây này các bạn nhớ
không? Đúng không? Function đúng không?
Cái hạo này nó sẽ nó sẽ lấy input vào là
x y nó sẽ trả về cái một cái cặp một cái
cặp tức là một cái cặp điểm của của từng
cái feature một. Cái feature nào mà nó
hay thay đổi cùng với cái output đồ ra y
ấ thì điểm nó sẽ cao. Các bạn hiểu một
cách đơn giản như vậy. Tức là nó sẽ tóm
lại nó sẽ đánh giá cái mức độ gọi là cái
mức độ thay đổi ảnh hưởng thì không hẳn.
Có thể trong thực tế có thể là ông X nó
không ảnh hưởng đến ông Y nhưng mà cái
thay đổi của X nó sẽ giúp cái việc tìm
ra cái thay đổi của Y ấy. Đấy thì ông
nào mà điểm cao hơn thì thì không. Tức
là correlation là một trường hợp riêng.
correlation ấy là chỉ áp dụng cho
coration nó là coration ấy là nó chỉ áp
dụng cho những cái dữ liệu dạng dạng
numerical feature thôi. Thế nhưng mà ở
đây khi mà các bạn kể cả dạng
categorical, kể cả diệu dạng categorical
các bạn vẫn có thể các bạn áp dụng cái
này được. Đấy các bạn số hóa thành vecor
các bạn vẫn áp dụng được đâ đây một cái
là một cái trường hợp rộng hơn. Tại vì
này correlation ấy là nó chỉ đánh giá
cái mối quan hệ tuyến tính thôi là mối
quan hệ bậc 1. Thế nhưng mối quan hệ
giữa x và y nó sẽ có rất nhiều mối quan
hệ khác nữa. Nó có thể bậc hai, bậc 3,
bậc phi tuyến, bậc logarit, bậc e, bậc
phân thức nó rất nhiều mối quan hệ khác
nữa. Thì cái này nó sẽ tổng quát hơn. Nó
sẽ tổng quát hơn. [hắng giọng]
Thật ra thì nó sẽ có rất nhiều những cái
hàm khác nhau. Những cái hàm tính điểm
nó sẽ có rất nhiều hàm khác nhau. Và mỗi
một cái hàm này nó sẽ phụ thuộc xem là
cái x của bạn là cái gì, y là cái gì và
đấy là đấy là bài toán gì. Nên các bạn
nhìn ở dưới này nó có rất nhiều cái
score function khác nhau. Thế nhưng mà
thông thường các bạn các bạn thông
thường chúng ta sẽ thông thường thì ví
dụ là với bài toán classification người
ta hay dùng cái cái này người ta gọi là
ch square test ch square test hoặc là
start. Đế đây đây với bài toán
classification. Nhưng mà các bạn chú ý
là với bài bài với bài toán này ấ thì
các cái feature nó phải là non negative,
nó là phải không âm thì mới dùng được.
Thế còn với bài toán re thì người ta hay
dùng cái f regression này. Rất là cụ thể
thì ví dụ các bạn học chương trình chính
quy các bạn có thể vào các bạn tìm hiểu
thêm cụ thể hơn nhưng mà thật ra nó cũng
không có quá cần thiết. Các bạn chỉ đơn
giản là nh là những cái hàm mẹp nó tính
điểm thế thôi. Ông nào mà hay thay đổi
tức là ông nào mà tôi có thể dựa vào cái
sự thay đổi của ông đấy để tôi có thể dự
đoán được cái y của tôi ấy thì điểm nó
sẽ cao. Còn ông nào mà ít dán được thì
điểm nó sẽ thấp mỗi thế thôi. Đấy thì
đấy cái và sau khi nó tính điểm như vậy
rồi nó sẽ chọn những cái ông nào mà điểm
cao nhất. Ví dụ đây k đây. Cái số k nó
sẽ thể hiện là các bạn muốn giữ lại bao
nhiêu mặc định đó nó bằng 10 bằng 10
đúng không? Mặc định 10 các bạn không
chỉ ra lại giữ lại 10 feature thế thôi.
Thế cách dùng rất là đơn giản các bạn.
Tất cả những cái documentation của nó
rất là tường minh luôn. Các bạn có cái
phần giới thiệu ở trên, các bạn có
documentation, các bạn có cả cái phần
example nữa. Được chưa? Đây này. Dùng
rất là dễ thôi. Được chưa? Cố phát xong.
Đưa vào cái score gì? Ví dụ của mình là
bài toán phân loại đúng không? Bài toán
phân loại đây. Classification này. Được
chưa? Mình phải đảm bảo cái feature mình
nó không âm đúng không? Của ta phân loại
rõ rồi. Nhưng mà feature liệu của mình
liệu có không âm hay không? Theo các bạn
các cái feature của chúng ta nó có đảm
bảo tất cả là không âm không?
Các bạn thấy là cái feure của chúng ta
nó có đảm bảo được cái điều kiện là nó
không âm không?
Theo các bạn cái feature của mình nó có
đảm bảo là nó không mâm không?
Không mâm không?
Mình nó chỉ tạ từ hai chỗ th một là
onhot, hai là TF hay DF. Hai ông này
liệu có âm được không? One hot có âm
được không?
Ô hay
one con thì không âm được, nó chỉ có 0
đến 1 thôi. TF IDF liệu có âm không? TF
IDF liệu có âm không?
Không âm được đúng không? Không âm được.
Hai này không âm được, dùng được đúng
không? Thế thế bây giờ dùng gì đây? Đúng
không? Nên nếu mà thật ra là nếu mà các
bạn học những cái chương trình chính quy
thường cái ch square này nó là một cái
thống kê khá là quan trọng, nó khá là
hay. Nhưng mà thật ra thì các bạn nếu
các bạn không phải không phải là đang
học trên trường thì các bạn cũng không
cần phải đi quá sâu vào thế thì thôi bây
gi các bạn nhìn dùng rất là dễ đây dùng
đi nhá một dòng import dòng import trên
này được chưa
import thế này và dưới đ ốp vào thôi đây
sẽ cái b đây chưa sẽ cái b nhá được chưa
mình cái phần tên này mình cho đây mình
sẽ gọi nó là
feature
selector được chưa chưa
nhưế này nhá. 20 thì hơi ít quá đúng
không? Bước trước các bạn thấy là mình
có đến gần 8000 mình chọn có 20 thì ít
quá mình thử chữ lại 1000 đi. Đưa 1000
nhá. Đ 1000 này. Được chưa? Khi mình xạ
1000 mình phải lưu lại cái kết quả này
đã nhá. Lưu lại kết quả này. Đ kết quả
đây quả mình đây. Đúng không? Đây là kết
quả mà sau khi mình à
đây kết quả sau khi mà mình dùng cái min
v min df v max df đấy đúng không các
bạn? Thế nó lên được ơ
nhầm copy đây chứ copy đây đúng không
lúc đầu 68 70 64 bây giờ là 73 75 71 này
đúng không được chưa các bạn giảm mất
sộn feature vừa nhanh hơn mà đây cái quả
mới đây đúng không
nhá
chưa
rồi
thế thì bây giờ bây giờ mình mình à
chạy thử thôi đúng mà trước khi chạy thử
mình sẽ test thử xem xem là có đúng là
nó chỉ ra 1000 không đúng không? Test
thử nhá. Mình bỏ cái ông này đi. Bỏ ông
này đi. Được chưa? Tôi chỉ có tôi chỉ có
tôi chỉ có hai bước thôi. Hai bước thôi
đúng không? Bây gi tôi sẽ a không như
này nữa
không tôi sẽ a
output này bằng model chfeit này ch
nếu mà chỉ có cái bước trên ấy nếu mà
chỉ có cái bước prepressor đấy thì thì
các bạn chuyển xên thôi là là đủ rồi tại
vì cái bước tiền xử lý các bạn chuyển x
thôi nhưng mà thêm cái bước này hoặc là
thêm cái bước cuối các bạn phải có thêm
cả y nữa tại vì là
vì là muốn tính cái muốn dùng ông này
thì cũng phải có cả x y mà ông này cũng
phải có cả x y đúng không có một ông thì
không không đủ Thấy chưa?
Green này. Put chsve này.
Ờ fit không bứt này vẫn fit fit fit
transform
thế này nhá. Chạy thử xem đúng là 1000
không nhá. Xem đúng 1000 nhá. Hãy giữ
lại 1000 feature quan trọng nhất trong
cả cái đống gần 8000 này. Được chưa? Tức
là tỉ lệ là 1 tri8 đấy. Đúng không?
Đấy 1000 rồi này là 1000 này. Thấy chưa?
Bây giờ mình chạy thôi đúng không? 1000
biết là ok rồi. Thì bây giờ chạy thôi
đúng không? Cho bước này vào đây chưa?
Cho chỗ này tắt đi chưa? Model sao dòng
print này nó vẫn màu này nhỉ?
Đây được chưa nhá. Xem bây giờ liệu 1000
feature so với 8000 feature cái nào tốt
hơn nhá. Đây là 8000 đúng không? Đây lúc
còn 8000 bây gi
1000 1000 feature nhá. Được chưa? Xem
8000 1000 cái nào nó tốt hơn.
Các bạn nghĩ là liệu có tốt hơn không?
Các bạn nghĩ bây giờ giảm còn 1000 có
tốt hơn không? Các bạn nhìn nhá. 8000 ở
trên. 8000 feature ở đây.
1000 ở dưới này.
Thế nào các bạn? 8000 trên 1000 dưới. A
là sao? tốt hơn đúng không? 73 lên 74
này một tí 75 lên 76 này cũng không
nhiều đúng không? Cũng không nhiều nhưng
mà rõ ràng đúng không? Vừa nhẹ hơn vừa
ít tiêu tố ít tài nguyên hơn chạy nhanh
hơn mà kết quả tốt hơn tội gì không dùng
đúng không? Đấy là 1000 nhá. 1000 đây.
1000 thôi. Bây gi mình chỉ copy mấy dòng
cuối thôi nhá. Copy ba cái dòng cuối
thôi. Mấy cái dòng trên có ai để ý đâu
đúng không? mấy dòng cuối này thôi.
Sợ này
được chưa? Bây giờ giảm nữa nhỉ? Giảm
nữa được không? Giảm thử giảm xong còn
500 nhá. 500 nhá. Vẫn đang giảm được.
Tất nhiên trong thực tế chúng ta sẽ
không làm thủ công này mà chúng ta sẽ
làm thế nào các bạn? Trong thực tế chúng
ta sẽ không ngồi thay thủ công này mà
chúng ta sẽ làm gì?
Chúng ta sẽ làm gì? Thay thủ công này
đây chỉ là đang ừ green search đúng
không? Green search chứ lại chứ ai lại
ngồi làm thủ công này đúng không? Green
search tất nhiên các bạn định nghĩa một
vài cái mốc ra đúng không? Vài cái mốc
ra ra mà đây đúng không? Thử 500 nhá.
500 này.
Ừ. Nó vào [tiếng cười]
machining chúng ta còn green search
được. Deep learning chịu không thể nào
green search được
đúng không? Bạn nào các bạn học cái khóa
sau các bạn thấy là trên một cái mô hình
mất vài tiếng rồi thì chịu không có cái
nào green search được. Đây các bạn nhìn
này.
Tốt hơn một tí đúng không? Vẫn tốt hơn
một tí thô. Th ra cũng xêm xêm đúng
không? Thằng xêm xêm nhưng mà tôi ít
feature mà xêm xêm thì tội gì đúng
không? Đấy đúng không? Đây là lên được
ông này lên được thêm một chỉ số 74 lên
75 còn ham kia giữ nguyên đúng không 500
tất nhiên chúng ta cũng không thể giảm
mãi được đúng không nó cũng chỉ có một
cái mức nào đấy thôi cũng không giảm mãi
được 500 ví dụ bây giờ mình chuyển còn
200 nhá 200 đi đúng không nó cũng không
thể giảm mãi được hiện tại đang thấy 500
có vẻ tốt nhất đúng không 500 thì ông
ông này lên được 75 này mình gọ gõ tạm
vào đây nhá 75 đúng không còn hai ông
kia giữ nguyên đúng không giảm mãi được
đúng không giảm 200 chẳng hạn xem có bao
nhiêu
Đây các bạn tôi đi này. Tôi đi này. Được
chưa? 75 thành 72 đúng không? Đấy chưa
cũng không giảm mãi được. Là một câu hơi
kìm là một câu gì là vì sao feature ít
feature hơn mà lại mô hình lại khôn. Nó
giống như này các bạn ạ. Hôm nọ mình nói
rồi nó cũng giống như kiểu là bây giờ
các bạn ôn thi cũng thế thôi đúng không?
Bây giờ các bạn ôn thi môn Toán đi đúng
không? Bây giờ mình vứt cho các bạn
10.000 bộ đề đúng không? Mình vết cho
bạn 10.000 bộ đề. Nhiều thông tin đấy,
nhiều feature đấy nhưng mà học đâu phải
là 10.000 là có phải nhiều tốt đâu. Bây
giờ mình thu lại cho các bạn là bây giờ
mình chỉ tập trung các bạn cho các bạn
ôn 20 đề quan trọng trọng nhất thôi.
Đúng không? Rõ ràng 20 20 đề nó ít hơn
100 10.000 đề nhưng mà bây gi sẽ được
focus hơn. 10.000 1000 đề thì các bạn sẽ
phải dàn sải dàn trải cái sự chú ý đi.
Còn bây giờ các bạn chỉ có 20 đề các bạn
chỉ focus thôi đúng không? Thì mình sẽ
focus vào những cái đề quan trọng nhất
thay vì là cái mình dàn trải ra thì nó
sẽ tốt hơn đúng không? Nhưng con người
nào máy nó cũng yền như thế đúng không?
Đôi khi không phải cứ nhiều mà tốt đúng
không? Mà quan trọng là cái nhiều nó có
chất lượng hay không đúng không? Tại vì
lúc ban đầu chúng ta có mấy 8000 nhưng
mà có phải ông nào cũng quan trọng đâu.
Nhiều ông là nó tầm quan trọng nó rất là
ít đúng không? Đấy đúng không? Tức là
mình lấy chất lượng thay mình lấy số
lượng đấy đúng không? tập trung vào vào
vào số lượng nhiều hơn là chất lượng
đúng không? Đấy các bạn chất lượng nhiều
hơn là số lượng đúng không? Thế các bạn
thấy không cũng không giảm mãi được đúng
không? 200 nó tồi đi rồi mình để thôi
mình để 500 nhá. Có phải 500 là ok nhất
đúng không? Đấy đúng không? Cái này mình
đang gọi là feature selection. Feature
selection đúng không? Tất nhiên tất cả
những cái thế này các bạn đều có thể
dùng green search đúng không? Các bạn
dùng green search các bạn tìm ra những
tham số dố tối ưu chứ ví dụ đây hai ông
này các bạn có thể dùng green search
đúng không? Dùng green search cái cũng
dùng green search 11 1213 đúng không?
Nhỡ đâu chỉ dùng uni nó nó đã đủ đủ tốt
rồi đúng không? Uni hoặc là by hoặc là
uniby vagram được chưa?
Cái gì ấ nhở lại nói cái gì được chưa?
Đấy nó kết quả đây hiện tại đây là kết
quả tốt nhất của chúng ta đây không sao
cái này vấn đề gì kết quả tốt nhất của
chúng ta được chưa tất nhiên chúng ta có
thể dùng green search chúng ta dùng lazy
predict thôi những cái gì mà những cái
bài trước chúng ta đã làm rồi thôi mình
ở đây mình không có bồi ra nữa được chưa
các bạn dùng green search thì cũng giống
như bài trước thôi đấy tên đúng không
tên này sa hai vạch rồi tên tiếp tên
tiếp tế tiếp được chưa cái bước trước
đấy dùng green search với ông này ông
này ông này đấy dùng như vậy cái này
cũng dùng green search đúng không 100
200 300 500 1000 các thứ ví dụ như vậy
được chưa Không.
Rồi đến đây có câu hỏi gì không?
Đến đây có bạn nào có thắc mắc gì không?
Đến đây có thắc mắc gì không?
Tiếp nhá.
Bây giờ theo các bạn
chúng ta đã tối ưu ở hai chỗ rồi. À chưa
chưa chưa còn một cái nữa. Còn một cái
nữa các bạn nhìn này. Cái bước này này.
Cái bước select best này ấ nó là một
bước nó rất là hữu ích để mình có thể
mình thu nhỏ số lượng độ feature đi đúng
không? Thế nhưng mà nó sẽ có một cái đặc
điểm là gì? Là chúng ta muốn
chúng ta muốn chỉ ra cái giá trị số k
này ấy thì chúng ta phải biết cái gì?
Nếu chúng ta muốn chỉ ra được cái giá
trị kêu thì chúng ta phải phải biết cái
gì trước? Chúng ta phải phải biết cái gì
trước? Nếu chúng ta muốn chỉ ra đây k là
bằng bao nhiêu đấy thì chúng ta phải
biết cái gì trước?
Phải biết cái gì trước?
Nếu chúng ta muốn chỉ ra cái giá trị K
đây một cái giá trị mà nó có ý nghĩa,
giá trị mà nó make sense, nó logic thì
mình phải biết cái gì trước?
Mình phải biết gì?
Mình phải biết là
muốn chỉ ra cái số k có ý nghĩa đây thì
mình phải biết cái gì trước các bạn?
Mình phải biết là trước cái bước này
mình đang có bao nhiêu feature đúng
không? Các bạn nghĩ xem mặc định nó là
10 đúng không? Mà nếu là 10 giả sử trước
cái bước này nó chỉ có 8 feature thôi
thì làm sao chọn 10 nó đâu có bị make nó
đâu có make sense đâu đúng không? Mà đây
mình để 500 như đâu trước bên này nó chỉ
có 300 thôi. Thế để 500 nó cũng chả có ý
nghĩa gì cả đúng không? Thì thì các bạn
phải biết là có bao nhiêu feure ở đây
thì thật ra muốn biết có bao nhiêu thì
các bạn chạy là xong thôi. Nhưng mà cũng
không phải lúc nào cũng có người ta
thích chạy phải chạy bước trước để xem
là có bao nhiêu feature. Nhiều khi người
ta sẽ không muốn giữ lại người ta sẽ
không muốn là select theo kiểu là giữ
lại bao nhiêu feature mà nó sẽ muốn
người ta sẽ muốn là giữ lại bao nhiêu
phần trăm số lượng feature. Tức là gì?
Ví dụ tôi có n feature tôi sẽ muốn giữ
giữ lại 50% 20% hay là 10% chẳng hạn. Ví
dụ như vậy đúng không? Thế bây giờ tôi
làm nào? Thì bây giờ tôi dùng cái select
này được chưa? Thay vì tôi dùng select
tôi sẽ dùng một cái gọi là select
percentage được chưa? Select percente.
Select KB là các bạn chỉ ra các bạn muốn
giữ lạy bao nhiêu còn đây các bạn phải
chỉ ra các bạn muốn dữ lạy bao nhiêu
phần trăm solure. Ví dụ ở đây mặc định
nó là 10 nó sẽ dạy 10%. Được chưa? Cách
dùng y chang ông kia nó chỉ khác mỗi cái
tên là thay vì ông kia ông đấy chỉ ra là
số k đây set kbs thì các bạn chỉ ra cái
số k đúng không? Score function vẫn thế
số k còn đây tôi sẽ chỉ ra là là
percenta thôi khác nhau mỗi thế thôi.
Được chưa? Nên cái nếu các bạn đây tôi
không muốn tôi phải biết cụ thể tôi chỉ
ra bao nhiêu thì tôi dùng cái set này
hai cách như nhau cách nào cũng được.
Mình thì mình vẫn hay dùng cái set hơn
thì nó phổ biến hơn
này chưa?
Được chưa? Dưới này tôi không dùng setb
nữa. Tôi
select percentile này
gì ấ nhở s
được chưa? Next sẽ à
CX đúng rồi
bằng à
10 tôi chỉ giữ lại 10% thôi được chưa?
10% thôi. Tôi không cần biết là trước
đây tôi có bao nhiêu. Tôi chỉ giữ lại
đúng 10% thôi. Được chưa? Hoặc là tôi
chỉ giữ lại 8% thôi đúng không?
Đây ở này đúng không? Đấy hai cách cách
nào cũng được. Cách trên thì các bạn
phải biết là trước đó nó có bao nhiêu
fature thì các bạn mới chỉ ra số k hiệu
quả được. Còn cái này các bạn chả khàn
biết. Tôi có bao nhiêu tôi cũng giữ lại
đúng 8%. Có nhiều tôi giữ nhiều, có ít
tôi giữ ít. Được chưa?
Thông thường hai cái bước này các bạn
chỉ dùng khi mà các bạn có rất nhiều
feature thôi. Còn khi mà gọ ít feature
thì không cần chưa? Giống kiểu
cái chi square ấy. Cái này tức là nó là
cái hàm để giúp đánh giá cái cái nó sẽ
đánh giá cái số điểm cho từng feature.
Số điểm tức là gì? Tức là cái feature
nào mà điểm nó mà mà nó có mà khi nó
thay đổi giá trị ý nó dẫn đến cái sự
thay đổi giá trị của y ý thì điểm nó sẽ
cao. Còn ông nào mà giá trị nó thay đổi
nó ít dẫn đến sự thay đổi của y điểm nó
sẽ thấp. Thế thôi nó sẽ tính điểm. Điểm
tức là cái mức độ thay đổi của x ảnh
hưởng đến mức độ thay đổi của y. Ông nào
mà ông đấy thay đổi dẫn đến y nó thay
đổi nhiều thì điểm nó càng cao và ngược
lại thôi.
Không các bạn chả cần điền. Đây ch này đ
này đây đây mình import trên này đấy mỗi
cái này thôi thự biện nó có hết rồi đây
các bạn thích các bạn có thể vào đây các
bạn vào các bạn đọc cái hướng dẫn này
đọc thì cũng được nhưng mà cũng không
cần thiết lắm bạn nào các bạnụ các bạn
đi nào thì cũng cũng không cần phải đi
quá sâu vào nó chưa
đấy hiểu một cách đơn giản nó sẽ đánh
giá cái không nhất thiết là cái x nó
phải ảnh hưởng đến y nó chỉ là gì tức là
khi mà x thay đổi nó y nó cũng thay đổi
tức là nó cũng dao động điều kiểu như
vậy được chưa
đấy các bạn có hai option Mình hay thứ
tiếp dùng cái âm này thôi. Tại vì thế là
muốn in ra cái sỗi fature của âm trên có
khó khó gì đâu. Còn không các bạn thấy
là các bạn dùng phần trăm cho nó nhanh
thì đây dùng cái dưới chưa?
Thế thôi.
Bây giờ các bạn thử nghĩ xem bây giờ
chúng ta đã có hai đúng không? Chúng ta
đã có một vài cái bước tối ưu đây một
này một này đúng không? Theo các bạn với
cái bộ rượu này theo các bạn còn cái gì
chúng ta có thể thử? Chúng ta nên thử để
chúng ta tối ưu hóa không?
Còn cái gì chúng ta có thể thử xem chúng
ta có giúp mô hình nó cải thiện hay
không.
Còn cái gì không?
Giảm số chiều á. Nhưng mà trên mình đã
vừa giảm rồi mà. Đúng. Trên vừa giảm
rồi, bây giờ giảm thì nó cũng có ừ có
nhách mới nhưng mà ra nó cũng
ừ thế bây giờ ý là ngoài giảm chiều đi
ok giảm chiều bằng s đầu bằng singular
singular value decomposition đúng không?
SD cũng được
mà còn cái gì nữa không ngoài giảm số
chiều chúng ta còn làm được cái gì nữa
không?
Có làm được cái gì nữa không?
Ừ. Ok rồi. Ờ ừ ok giả chậ ừ thay đổi mô
hình rồi còn gì nữa được thay đổi mô
hình cũng là một cách
còn gì nữa thay đổi tham số thay đổi
tham số thì chính là dùng green search
đúng không mình nói là dùng green search
đúng không dùng green search thì ok nó
bằng một cách ừ đúng rồi dùng green
search được ok còn cái gì nữa cái gì mà
chúng ta chưa từng làm bao giờ mình muốn
hỏi những cái thứ chúng ta chưa từng làm
bao giờ tạo thêm feature.
Tạo nên feature
nếu các bạn muốn tạo nên feature, cách
dễ nhất là gì? Các bạn có biết ấy, nếu
các bạn thích tạo feature, các bạn có
biết cách dễ nhất là làm cách nào không?
Đố các bạn biết bây giờ nếu mà muốn thêm
feature ấy cách dễ nhất là chúng ta dùng
cái gì? Chúng ta dùng cái gì ở đây?
Nếu các bạn muốn thêm feature, cách dễ
nhất là chúng ta làm cái gì ở đây?
Làm gì ở đây? Nếu muốn thêm feature,
nếu muốn thêm fature cách dễ nhất chúng
ta làm gì ở đây? Nếu muốn thêm VIP chưa?
Cái chỗ mong bôi đen này. Cái chỗ m bôi
đen này.
Kết hợp feature đã có tạo thành phế mới.
Kết hợp được nhưng mà nhưng mà kết hợp
xong rồi để làm gì? Vấn đề là để làm gì
mới được chứ đúng không? các cái feature
của bạn đến cái bước này ấ feature nó là
toàn những cái thứ mà con người không
hiểu. Rồi các bạn muốn kết hợp kiểu gì
các bạn lấy các bạn lấy x1 nhân với x2
các bạn lấy x1 + x2 bây giờ kết hợp kiểu
gì bây giờ hay là x1 + x2 bình bây giờ
đúng không? Kết hợp kiểu gì mới được
chứ? Cách các bạn thấy feure các bạn
cách nhất ấy các bạn thay đổi mô hình
này không dùng mô hình này nữa thành một
mô hình khác các bạn ấy là các bạn có
biết là thay đổi th mô hình gì không?
Muốn thêm feature các bạn biết thay đổi
thành mô hình gì không?
Chữ thầy giả thầy hết rồi.
Chữ thầy thôi mọi người về không ôn bài
đúng không? Về không ôn bài đúng không?
Chỉ mỗi tuần về đây học hai buổi thôi
đúng không? đã ôn bài gì cả học đến nửa
khóa rồi
nên tit vào những cái sample if phân tử
đúng rồi một cái là over một cái overing
cái đúng rồi overing là underling mà
chúng ta gọi là balance data đúng không
các bạn không biết là muốn thêm vure
chúng ta xoay đổi mô hình làm cái gì ở
đây à học rồi là học rồi
từ học xong không ôn lại bài đúng không
ôn lại bà
Rồi các bạn thế bây giờ với bạn à bạn
bạn Hiếu B bài nói là gì? Là chúng ta có
thể chúng ta thực hiện chúng ta thực
hiện balance data đúng không? Balance
data. Balance sẽ có hai việc. Một là các
bạn có thể over class đa số, hai các bạn
under class. À sorry over class hoặc là
under class đa số đúng không?
Thế thế bây giờ đây đúng không các bạn?
Nhìn này. Dựu chúng ta đ nhìn chung là
nó mất cân bằng đúng không? Tôi sẽ để
tôi cân bằng chúng đi đúng không? cân
bằng ch đi. Thế thì trong quá trình học
chúng ta có nói một chúng ta có một cái
a chúng ta có một cái thư viện tên nó là
đây nó tên là imbalance learn. Đây các
bạn sẽ nhìn thấy cái logo của nó nó rất
là tương đồng với s learn nhá. Nhìn này
đây các bạn nhìn đây
các bạn nhìn logo giống nhau không?
Đấy ông này có thể gọi một cái thư viện
con. cái thư viện con được chưa?
Thế này dùng dễ lắm. Cài rất là dễ. Đ
cài các bạn có mỗi cái dòng pit cách
install cách này thôi này. Cách imellent
learn đây này. Đ đây cho các bạn comment
nhá. Đây copy này. Mở cho b ra gõ vào
xong. Được chưa?
Được chưa?
Thế thế ta cài xong dùng dễ lắm. Đây ví
dụ mình muốn over nhá. Over cho nó quen
thuộc nhá. Over dùng rất là dễ. Over nó
có nó có mấy cái
nó có mấy cái kỹ thuật như này đây.
Ờ w qu W đây bình thường các bạn dùng
cái cơ bản nhất là cái random over
sampler này. Cái này nó tác dụng nó chỉ
nó chỉ nhân bản hóa những cái simple
thuộc class cũ thôi. Nhưng mà nhân bản
hóa này nó sẽ không có cái sự đa dạng.
Không có cái sự đa dạng. Tức là gì? Ví
dụ một một cái bản nó sẽ thành kiểu
photocopy thành 10 bản. Thế thôi. Dùng
thì rất là dễ. Đây dùng các bạn nhìn
nhá. này một cái dòng này mình thì mình
cài rồi mình thì mình cài rồi nên là môi
trường mình có rồi các bạn chưa cài các
bạn gõ đúng cái câu lệnh mình vừa cho
các bạn vào vào terminal á được chưa
được chưa random mler nhá được chưa rất
là dễ đây các bạn có một cái dòng trên
và dòng dưới này nhá dòng trên này
dòng trên nhá là mler này
đâ
Mình sẽ thực hiện over mình sẽ thực hiện
over
ờ trước hay là sau khi mình tách bộ
chuyên bộ test các bạn nhỉ? Chúng ta sẽ
thiện oversling. Câu này mình đã từng
hỏi rồi đúng không? Cái buổi học lý
thuyết từng hỏi rồi mới thiện overling
hoặc là mình thiện balance data đúng
không? Th hiện B lên xa trước hay là sau
khi chúng ta tách bộ trên bộ test này
trước hay sau?
Sau đúng không? Tại vì trước nó sẽ có
khả năng nó bị data lckage đúng không?
Th hiện sau đúng không? Sau đây tách
xong này. Được chưa?
Z bằng 0 được chưa? Bây giờ mà mặc bao
nhiêu cũng được biết được các bạn fix
một cái số cố định chưa? Sau các bạn sẽ
có cái đoạn là là là này à đâu rồi nhỉ?
Nó sẽ có đoạn là fit
nó có đoạn là fit
đâ rồi
fit thôi. À xin chào các bạn
cho phum nhỉ.
Make p cũng không cần thiết lắm
đây. Dùng kiểu đơn giản thôi
đây. Các bạn chờ tí nhá. Đây
này à fit resample đây resample khác một
tí đúng không? Chỗ này
ờ xem temp trên bl này được chưa?
À x đây exchange
train
được chưa?
này,
train này, value
out này. Được chưa?
À mình phải in lúc trước về lúc sau chứ
mình mới biết là nó khác nhau ra quên
mất
trên và dưới nhá. Được chưa? Exit luôn
nhá. Exit luôn được chưa?
Đây các bạn nhìn này. Đây lúc trước đây.
Lúc trước đây. Lúc sau đây
trước, trên sau và dưới đúng không?
Các bạn thấy là nếu mình áp dụng over
sim này các bạn thấy nó thế nào? Cảm
nhận của các bạn
các bạn thấy nào?
Ừ, không ổn lắm nhở. Có bạn nào có thể
mô tả rõ cái sự không ổn ở đây nó là gì
không? Ừ, nhìn mình nó không ổn lắm. Có
bạn nào có bạn nào có thể miêu tả mình
cái sự
theo các bạn cái sự không ổn ở đây là là
gì vân hóa được các class á các bạn khác
thì sao mình muốn nghe cả các bạn khác
nữa. Theo các bạn sự không ổn lên nó là
gì?
Ừ.
Các bạn có nhớ là cái hôm chúng ta học
về cân bằng dữ liệu hoặc về balance data
ấy, chúng ta nói về kỹ thuật ngữ, tức là
người ta gọi là chúng ta đang muốn
balance data đúng không? Balance data là
cân bằng dữ liệu. Nhưng cái mục tiêu của
chúng ta ấy không phải là để làm cho dữ
liệu bằng nhau chắc chắn chặn đúng
không? chúng ta gọi là cân bằng dữ liệu
nhưng mục tiêu của chúng ta không phải
là để cho rượu nó bằng nhau ch% chạm.
Tại vì sao? Làm như vậy nó sẽ đèn thay
đổi cái phân bố. Các bạn có nhớ cái hôm
chúng ta học về phân chia bộ trên bộ va
bộ test ấy mình nói là gì? Là cái
distribution cái phân bố của cái dữ liệu
ấy bộ trên bộ va test nó phải tương
đương nhau đúng không? Chứ mình không
muốn là nó bằng nhau chăn chặn đúng
không? Bằng nhau chăn chặn như vậy thì
sao? Cái distribution của bộ trest nó sẽ
khác nhau. Tất nhiên khi chúng ta thực
hiện balance data, chúng ta sẽ chỉ thực
hiện balance data cho bộ train thôi.
Chúng ta sẽ không đạt động đến bộ va bộ
test. Nên là khi chúng ta balance data
ấy thì chắc chắn là distribution của
rượu là nó ở bộ trên và hai bộ kia nó đã
khác nhau rồi. Cái đấy đều chúng ta phải
chấp nhận. Nhưng chúng ta cũng không
muốn là nó nó nó
tuyệt đối như thế này. Chúng ta không
muốn nó như thế này đúng không? Như này
nó không ổn đúng không? Chúng ta chỉ
muốn nó đỡ mất cân bằng thôi. Được chưa?
Đỡ mất cân bằng thôi. Thế thì bây giờ ấy
thứ nhất không đây cái đỡ mất cân bằng
là thứ nhất. Cái thứ hai nữa ấy là cái
random over này thì nó giúp cho chúng ta
có ok tôi có thể có thể có thêm nhiều
sample cho cái bộ trin
cho các cái class thiểu số
tức là tôi chỉ làm tăng cái tần tần suất
nó xuất hiện thôi nhưng mà về cái sự đa
dạng thì nó chả tăng cái gì cả sự đa
dạng vẫn y trang chả khác gì cả đúng
không bây giờ tôi muốn là tăng tôi phải
đa dạng cơ thì các bạn nhìn đây nhá nếu
ở đây tôi không dùng cái random over này
tôi sẽ có cái ký tội khác ví dụ cái ký
tượng smooth này đây là một cái đợn rất
là nổi tiếng nổi tiếng cái thời ngày xưa
mình học bây giờ nó có nhiều kỹ thuật
khác nữa rồi. Cái smoote này thì nó sẽ
cái smooth này cho các bạn xem nhá.
Smoot lại như này. Tức là smooth này nó
là viết tắt của sinic
sin
minor minority
đây đây đây viết tắt của này tích mạ đ s
m o t
đây này. Smoot này thấy chưa? Nó chỉ đơn
giản là gì? Tức là tôi sẽ tạo ra những
cái rượu tổng hợp đúng không? Đây là
tổng hợp. Tổng hợp tức là gì? Nó giống
kiểu nhựa tổng hợp ấy. Nhựa tổng hợp nó
là nhựa nhưng mà nó có những cái đặc nó
có những cái thứ mới nó tức là nó có
những cái đặc trưng cũ và có những cái
đặc trưng mới. Thế thôi đúng không? Thì
đây cái nó nó kiểu kiểu như vậy. Kiểu
kiểu như vậy. Thế thì bây giờ tôi dùng
cái tôi dùng cái đây là cái đây là cái
mà chúng ta vừa nói nhá. Cái random over
simler đâu rồi? Trên đâu rồi? Đây cái
cách chúng ta vừa nói thì trên không nói
gì đúng không các bạn? Như này cách ở
trên này thì cái dự cắt thiểu số là tím
nó vẫn cứ là tím thôi đúng không? Nhưng
nó sẽ nhiều hơn nhưng các bạn nhìn này ở
dưới này. Ở dưới này các bạn nhìn thấy
đây chúng ta có kỹ thuật ví dụ đây là
đây là random over sender này được chưa?
Ờ đúng không? Còn đây các bạn này cái số
mode này các bạn không nó đa dạng hơn
đúng không? Nhưng cái c mới nó sẽ không
giống hoàn toàn về C nó sẽ đa dạng hơn.
Một cách có thể rất là đơn giản để tạo
dữ liệu mới là gì? Là tôi dùng giống
kiểu Kistel ấy. Tôi gom ba cái ông ở gần
nhất. Ba ông gần tôi ba ông bất kỳ của
class đấy tôi lấy cái ông trung bình ở
giữa thì tôi thành dữ liệu mới thôi. Tất
nhiên kỹ này nó sẽ phức tạp hơn thế
nhưng mà nhìn chung bạn hiểu cái đơn
giản lên thì tôi sẽ tạo từ những cái sle
cũ tôi tổng tạo những cái sle mới nó
chia sẻ những cái đặc trưng mới như nó
chia sẻ những cái đặc trưng cũ nhưng mà
nó cũng có những cái điểm mới nữa được
chưa? Đấy smooth hoặc là adasin nó đều
là những cái rượu kiểu như vậy. Tức là
gì? Nó tạo rượu mới nó tăng cái sự đa
dạng nữa. Được chưa?
Thế nhưng mà có một cái điểm này, cái
smooth này ấ là nó chỉ hoạt động với dữ
liệu dạng mà toàn numerical thôi. Smooth
là nó chỉ hoạt động với kiểu toàn
numerical thôi. Thế là nếu mà các bạn có
feature ví dụ trong trường hợp chúng ta
ấy,
trong trường hợp ta tại vì các bạn hiểu
này, lúc chúng ta balance data ấy là
chúng ta thực hiện cái lúc ban đầu, tức
là cái lúc mà rượu nó vẫn là còn đang là
text, nó vẫn là location, title,
description vân vân. nó vẫn là tex chứ
nó chưa được số hóa. Thế nên lúc mà nếu
các bạn cứ táng nguyên cái smooth vào
đây thì nó sẽ lỗi. Cái này nhá. Cho vào
smoke vào đây nhá. Được chưa? Mình cho
vào đây này là cái gì nó sẽ lỗi luôn.
Cái random m thì không sao tại vì nó chỉ
đơn giản là doucate thôi thì không vấn
đề gì. Nhưng mà với cái ông smote này
các bạn chạy này thì kiểu gì nó cũng sẽ
lỗi ngay. Tại vì là rượu chúng ta nó lại
có cả dữ liệu mà thật rau chúng ta toàn
bộ thì là đều không phải dạng số nó đều
là tex cả đúng không? Kể cả dượu là
catorical là nó đã không chạy được rồi.
Nó chiều động ví dụ dạng số thôi. Đây
các bạn nhìn nhá. Cái gì nó cũng báo lỗi
đỏ lòm này.
Đây các bạn thấy chưa? Đây này. Thấy
chưa? Nó không convert được. Đấy. Sm bản
gốc thì nó không convert được. Thế thì ở
đây người ta cho thế thì cái cái smoot
này ấ chúng ta có thêm một vài những cái
biến thể. Chúng ta có một vài những cái
biến thể của nó. Ờ smooth đây nó có đ bỏ
cái chỗ F đâ rồi
các bạn nhìn nhá. Nếu mà
bản gốc đây nó có hai cái bản nữa là cái
bản smote
NC. Smoot NC là nó sẽ làm việc với cái
loại mà nó bao gồm tức là feature có thể
bao gồm cả số và cả Nummer và cả cater.
Nhưng điều kiện là gì? Điều kiện là các
bạn phải có tối thiểu một của là Numic
Feature. Các bạn phải có tối thiểu là
một của là Numic Feature thì các bạn mới
dùng cái smooth NC này được. Còn nếu các
bạn chỉ toàn categorical thôi thì nó sẽ
không chạy. Thế chúng ta có một cái kiểu
cuối nữa là smooth smooth Này
smooth N sẽ có thể là các bạn chỉ có
categorical nó vẫn chạy bình thường.
Được chưa? Này này không không phải viết
tắc của num numeric đâu. Nó viết tắc của
nominal. Nominal hay là nó cũng cũng ok
cả. Đấy nó dữ liệu các bạn chỉ có calic
thôi. Các bạn dùng cái này sm này được
chưa?
Giờ mình ốp vào đây. Sm ốp vào đây. Được
chưa? Tôi dùng smart này tôi tạo dữ liệu
mới này. Được chưa?
Tí nhá.
>> [khịt mũi]
>> Lỗi lỗi gì các bạn? Nhìn này. Nó tạo raã
tạo ra những cái sle mới dựa vào những
cái sle cũ thì mà đây mình đang có một
cái tham số nó to quá. Đây này. Expect
neighbor này. Đúng không? Nó dựa vào
những cái điểm xung gần nhau để nó tạo
ra sample mới. Tại vì mình có một mình
có một cái class mình có ít lắm. Mình có
ba sample thôi. Ông này các bạn ông toàn
sáu thứ này thì nó nhiều quá đúng không?
Simple nó đang to quá. Trên này nó có
những tham số gì? Nó có cái
đây nó có cái K label này. Sau đây nó
ghi là 5
sẽ là là nó đấy. Đúng là nó đâ này thì
mình cho số bé thôi. Mình cho hai thôi
chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như vậy thôi. Cho hai
thôi đúng không? Nên là nhiều quá thì
tôi cho hai thôi.
Ai nhở? Ví dụ như vậy à? Alo, xin lỗi
không phải trên nhá.
Đây
đúng rồi. Chả tách cũng được. Thật ra
các bạn nhìn này. Ở đây ấ thật ra ấy
mình đang chỉ muốn phân tích là gì? Tức
là chúng ta đang dùng nó để chúng ta tạo
ra những cái sble mới thôi. Còn thật ra
ấy những cái sble mới nó có xí hay không
ấy thì chúng ta chưa biết được.
Cái việc balance data ấy nó có giúp cho
việc là mô hình nó dự án tốt hay không ý
chúng ta phải thử. Thật ra với dư dạng
tex ấy cái phép những cái phép cân bằng
rượu này nó sẽ không quá hiệu quả nhá.
Với dữ liệu dạng tex cái việc này nó sẽ
không quá hiệu quả. Nếu mà nó là dữ liệu
dạng kiểu là dữ liệu dạng kiểu là
catorical
ví dụ quốc gia các thứ chẳng hạn thì nó
ok. Còn thật ra nó tex dài nàyấy cái
việc mà chúng ta dùng smote này nó sẽ
không không quá hiệu quả. Tại vì cái
smote này nó thiết kế không phải để dành
cho những diệu dạng như này. Thế nhưng
mà đây mình đang muốn chỉ cho các bạn
cách để chúng ta có thể oversampling
thôi. Còn thật ra với bài này áp dụng nó
sẽ không có nhiều cái không không có
nhiều ý nghĩa đâu. Tại vì nó là một cái
văn xuôi. Văn xuôi không áp dụng đến kỹ
thu truyền thống như này được. Được
chưa?
Thật ra thì với NLP thì cái việc là
overing nó rất là hạn chế gần như là
không có cách nào quá hiệu quả. Tại vì
là nó là văn xuôi mà ảnh người ta có thể
thự ví dụ người ta flip ảnh, người ta
lật ảnh, người ta rotate ảnh thì còn ok.
Còn NLP rất là khó
các bạn nhá. Tăng này đúng không? Nhưng
mà chúng ta không muốn nó tuyệt đối như
này đúng không? Chúng ta không muốn nó
tuyệt đối này. Chúng ta muốn ví dụ như
là ba ông này ít chẳng hạn tôi cho lên
thành
không 100 này ít nhở. Ba ông này ví dụ
cho lên thành à 500 ông này cho thành
1000. Ví dụ như vậy chẳng hạn đúng
không? Tôi muốn tăng lên như vậy chứ tôi
không muốn là bằng nhau chắc tình trận
này. Tôi không muốn như này. Thế bây giờ
tôi mà muốn tôi sẽ control được cái việc
là mỗi ông có bao nhiêu ấy thì các bạn
nhìn thấy tôi sẽ có một cái tham số ở
đây. Đó là cái samling strategy này.
Mình sẽ truyền vào một cái dictionary.
Cái dictionary để chỉ ra là mỗi một cái
class tôi muốn bao nhiêu. Rất là dễ thôi
anh nhá. Bạn xem thử nhá.
Đây nhá. Ờ state này mình sẽ thêm một
cái nữa là ch nào thì đẹp nhỉ. Một đây.
2 đây. 3 đây nhá.
Strat nhá.
Bằng này được chưa?
Chu cụ thể nhá. Ông này thì tôi muốn là
lên thành
500 cũng hơi hơi nhiều.
500 đi. Simple vậy. Vậy nhá. Thì cho các
bạn xem ví dụ thôi. Hôm nay cho nàynh
cho 500 này.
Ông này cho 500
được chưa?
Ông này cho này nghìn
ví dụ như vậy. Được chưa? Ông nào bỏ qua
thì coi như là không làm gì cả. Được
chưa? Ông nào bỏ qua thì coi như không
làm gì cả. Ông này giữ nguyên. Ông này
giữ nguyên. Chạy thử nhá.
Đấy vậy chưa? Đẹp chưa?
Đấy chưa? Cân bằng hơn rồi này. Được
chưa? Tức là theo cái ý của mình được
chưa? Tất nhiên là như mình nói rồi với
dơ dạng NP thì cái dùng cái kỹ thuật
overspring này nó sẽ không không quá
hiệu quả tại vì là nó không phải feature
kiểu bình thường đúng không? Chúng ta có
thể chúng ta miễn cưỡng chúng ta làm thì
vẫn được nhưng mà nhìn chung nó sẽ không
quá tốt. Nó sẽ khác với ví dụ dạng kiểu
quốc tịch hoặc là quốc tịch hoặc là màu
sát chẳng hạn thì nó sẽ ok hơn. Đấy
nhưng kiểu này nó sẽ nó sẽ ít hiệu quả.
Được chưa?
Rồi balance ra là một cái các bạn có thể
thử đúng không? Mình không đảm bảo là nó
sẽ giúp các bạn mô hình nó tốt hơn nhưng
mà cái đây là thứ có thể thử. Theo các
bạn ngoài balance data thì có việc gì
chúng ta có thể chúng ta thử được.
Ngoài balance data thì có việc gì các
bạn nghĩ là chúng ta có thể thử nữa nào?
Có việc có thể thử nữa thử thôi. Nó có
thật sự nó có tốt hay không thì biết
đúng không?
Emí xem xem cái
này các cái level như này được chưa?
Theo các bạn có cái việc gì chúng ta có
thể thử nữa để xem là liệu nó có một
giúp mình tốt hơn hay không.
Việc gì nào?
M thử nghĩ xem.
Các bạn bây giờ ngoài cái việc các bạn
balance đ các bạn over các bạn under đi
Thì theo các bạn còn cái gì còn cái gì
các bạn có thể thử để xem là liệu nó có
giúp cho mình tốt hơn hay không.
[khịt mũi]
Nghĩ xem các bạn mình đang gợi ý các bạn
những cái gì đang ở trên màn hình này là
g là gợi ý cho các bạn đấy. Những cái gì
phải gợi ý mình đang hiện trên màn hình
cho các bạn này.
Còn cái gì nào?
Không anh không ai có idea gì. Ơ thế bây
giờ nếu mà không có mình ở đây các bạn
làm thế nào? Chạy lại vứt hết vào ai?
Thử nghĩ xem có cái nào nữa không? Có
cái gì các bạn có thể thử được không?
Bây giờ cái mô hình của mình nhá. Đúng
không? Nhìn chung là performance của mô
hình của mình trên các cái class thiểu
số nó sẽ thấp đúng không? Mấy ông có ít
sample thường performance nó sẽ thấp
đúng không? Thì bây giờ theo các bạn bây
giờ mình muốn mình mình
muốn làm sao cho cái performance của
mình nó
cao hơn trên những cái class này thì
theo các bạn có cái gì chúng ta có thể
thử?
Mình nghĩ xem nghĩ xem có cái gì mà có
thể thử nào.
Tăng trọng số là một cách. Ok. Đấy, đấy
là một cách đúng rồi. Giống kiểu bây giờ
thay vì một cái bài mà câu nào cũng từng
lấy điểm thì tôi sẽ cho những câu điểm
nó cao lên. Đúng, đấy là một cách. Đấy
là một cách. Còn cách gì nữa? Tăng nhọng
số lên. Còn cách còn cách gì nữa?
Còn cách gì nữa?
Tăng số lượng thiểu số hoặc giảm số
lượng đa số thì nó chính là balance
data. Mình vừa mới nói xong còn gì nữa.
Vừa nói vừa vừa nói balance data thì
balance data nó chính là over samling
với underling. Đúng không? Thì có phải
over là tăng thiểu số, under là giảm đa
số đúng. Vừa mới nói rất lời xong. Khổ
lân tôi
đúng không? Vừa nói xong gì nữa nào các
bạn? Còn cái gì chúng ta chưa thử cho có
thể thử nữa các bạn. Focus chưa? Focus
nhá. Đang học nên sao phải focus nhá.
Đừng để tâm hồ trên m các bạn nhá. Còn
việc gì chúng ta có thể làm nữa nào. Còn
gì chúng ta có thể thử nữa nào. Theo các
bạn mình đang gợi ý là gì? Là đấy là
những cái ông cái ông class thiểu số
performance nhìn chung nó đang thấp đúng
không? Bây giờ tôi muốn cho mô hình nó
tốt hơn. Những những cái class thiểu số
này tôi làm thế nào? Theo các bạn có
nào?
Nếu không dùng AI, nếu không phải người
ý tạo cột đánh dấu thông tin quan trọng
từ kiến thức nghiệp vụ các tạo cột đánh
đánh dấu thông tin quan trọng từ các
kiến thức nhiệm vụ các dấu hiệu quan
trọng để mô học trực tiếp từ các dấu
hiệu này thay vì học số liệu
tạo đánh dấu thông tin quan trọng
tạo cuộc đánh dấu thông tin quan trọng
mình Mình không nói là không thể nhưng
mà nghe có vẻ
hơi khó thực hiện nhỉ. Có vẻ hơi khó
thực hiện đúng không? Ok. Cũng có thể ừ
tức thì mình sẽ cần phải có một ai đấy
có chuyên môn đúng không? Người ta
chuyên môn về cái việc là phân loại các
cái job này. Ok.
Còn cái gì nữa các bạn? Còn cái gì? Còn
cái gì mà chúng ta có thể chúng ta
impment được ngay không?
Đấy mình đang gợi ý đấy. Có ba ở đây
chúng đang có một vài class rất thiểu
số, rất ít sample luôn. Đây này bao này
rất ít rất ít sample luôn.
Bây giờ tôi muốn làm sao giúp cho mình
tăng cái performance trên trên máy công
kiểu số này. Tôi có cách nào?
Chỉnh ngưỡng là một cách. Chỉnh ngưỡng
là một cách. Đúng rồi. Chỉnh ngưỡng.
Chỉnh ngưỡ trường triệu này nó nó có
nghĩa là như nào? Bạn nào có thể mô tả
cái việc chỉnh ngưỡng ở đây có nghĩa là
gì? Chỉnh ngưỡng ở đây là là như nào?
Bạn nào có thể mô tả được cái việc bảo
chỉnh ngưỡng đi. Chỉnh ngưỡng là chỉnh
ngưỡng. Ngưỡng gì bây giờ? Chỉnh này
làm nào.
Làm nào? Bây giờ
tăng trọng số vãy các bạn vừa đề cập rồi
đúng không? Tăng trọng số để nó phạt mô
hình nó tức là tăng trọng số của những
cái của những cái sle class. Đúng rồi,
vậy vừa trên kia với bạn bảo tăng trọng
số cá thiểu số đây. Bạn bạn Hiếu bạn vừa
vừa vừa vừa nói ở trên rồi đúng không?
Có một cách nữa mà chưa bạn nào nghĩ đến
là gì? Là mình sẽ
mình sẽ làm sao? Mình sẽ gộp ba ông này
lại thành một class.
Bây giờ mình sẽ chạy theo kiểu hai tầng.
Người ta gọi là hydra. Hydra tức là phân
tầng. Đấy.
Phân tầng có nghĩa là gì đây?
Phân tầng có nghĩa là gì? Phân tầng đúng
hierarch classification.
Phân loại phân tầng tức là gì? Lúc ban
đầu nhá. Mô hình mình đây đúng không? Nó
sẽ có bốn class đúng không? 1 2 3 ba
class đầu tiên thì chính là ba class.
Đây chính là ba ông nhiều này. Ba ông
đầu tiên này đúng không? Còn ba ông này
tôi gộp lại th một class số 4 đúng
không? Ba ông này tôi gọi class số 4
đây. Ba này gọi là đây được chưa?
Đấy 456 ở đây. Sau đó tôi lại có một cái
mô thứ hai nữa phân lại riêng bao ông
này thôi. Đây người ta gọi là hyoc
clustering đúng không? Hycle
classification.
Chữ này chắc mình viết sai đấy. Mình
viết
đây. Hở đây. Đấy được chưa? Đây đúng
không? Mô hình phân loại phân tầng. Phân
loại phân tầng đúng không? Tức là có hai
tầng đúng không? Bây giờ ba ông thiểu số
tôi gộp lại thành một class tôi tăng số
lượng sle lên mà đúng không? Bây giờ để
ba này nó ít quá cộng lại không nó được
gần trăm đúng không? Sau đó thì tôi sẽ
mô hình phân loại 1 2 3 và 4. Bây giờ
khi nào mà mô hình nó dự đoán là nó thu
về class số 4 tôi lại cho nó đi qua một
cái mô hình thứ hai nữa ân lại ra được
chưa? Đấy tôi gộp lại vào nhau. Nó giống
kiểu như này các bạn. Nó giống kiểu như
này. Bây giờ ấy các bạn muốn sử dụng cái
mô hình để phân loại xem để mô hình nó
dự đoán cố tịch của một người đúng
không? Thế bây giờ các bạn bắt một cái
mô hình nó dự đoán 200 cố tịch cùng một
lúc chẳng hạn nó rất là khó. Thì bây gi
các bạn sẽ làm một kiểu phân tầng. Tức
là đầu gì? Tầng đầu tiên là các bạn cho
một cái mô hình nó phân loại ờ theo châu
lục châu Á, Châu Âu, Châu Phi, Châu Mỹ,
Châu Đại Dương. Năm châu lục thôi. Mỗi
một cái châu lục này các bạn sẽ có một
cái mô hình con. Châu Á nó chỉ quan tâm
giữa Việt Nam, Trung Quốc, Ấn, Ấn Độ,
Nhật Bản, Hàn Quốc, Malaysia các thứ
đúng không? Châu Âu nó chỉ quan tâm đến
Pháp, Đức, Anh. Kiểu kiểu như vậy. Được
chưa? Đấy là phân loại phân tầng như vậy
đây y trang như vậy y trang như vậy đúng
không tôi sẽ thay vì tôi để nó dựa ấm
ngay một cục lần tôi sẽ phân chia nhỏ ra
phân hành những cái tầng khác nhau được
chưa giống các bạn làm việc ở công ty
cũng thế thôi đúng không ông ông tổng
giám đốc thì hôm nay đây phải phân chia
việc cho cho các giám đốc giám đốc thì
lại phải phân chia việc cho trưởng phòng
trưởng phòng cho nhân viên ví dụ kiểu
như vậy chẳng hạn đây thì cũng y chang
như thế được chưa
đây ý tưởng là như vậy đúng không mình
sẽ để mình gộp mấy ông tiểu số lại vào.
Thế nhưng với cái bài này, với cái bài
này nếu mà chúng ta gộp như vậy ấ chúng
ta gộp bao này lại ấy thì với bài này nó
sẽ có một cái vấn đề. Nếu chúng ta gộp
các cái các tiểu dôi lại nó sẽ có cái
vấn đề.
Vấn đề đây là là gì?
Nếu ở đây mình gộp ba cái ông thiểu số
này lại nó sẽ không cái vấn đề. Vấn đề
đây là là gì?
Vấn đề đây là gì hả các bạn?
Vấn đề đây là
gì?
Vấn đề đây là gì?
Model sẽ có để đánh thứ tự ưu tiên cho
các máy class. Đánh thứ tự là gì? Đánh
thự tiên là gì? Không tôi gộp ba lại tôi
có một cái mô hình thứ hai nữa mà. Mô
hình thứ hai phân loại riêng bao âm này
mà. Cả lớp thử nghĩ xem nếu bây giờ mình
gộp ba này lại với nhau nó sẽ có một cái
vấn đề là vấn đề gì.
Nghĩ kỹ xem
nó có 10 vấn đề.
Mình gợi ý nhá. Nó sẽ nó vẫn chạy bình
thường. Nó vẫn chạy nó vẫn chạy bình
thường. Nó sẽ không có lỗi gì về mặt kỹ
thuật. Nó không có lỗi về mặt kỹ thuật
nhưng nó sẽ có một cái lỗi về mặt logic.
Được chưa? Đây giảm độ chính xác chi
tiết của các club không sao lại giảm độ
chi tiết? Mình có mình có riêng một cái
mô hình chỉ để phân loại ba ông này cơ
mà. Mình có riêng một cái mô hình thứ
hai để phân loại bao này mà. Nó phải chi
tiết hơn chứ đúng không? Tôi dùng hai
ông cơ mà.
Đây không phải cái vấn đề đây nó không
phải về lỗi kỹ thuật là nó là về lỗi
logic mà nó chỉ ra cái vấn đề ở đây
tất nhiên gộp nó phải khác nhau nó mà
máy viết chuyện nó mà giống nhau thì nó
thu về cùng một class rồi đúng không bao
này mà giống nhau nó thu về cùng một
class xử rồi chứ nó người ta cần gì phải
phân ra nữa. Hiển nhiên chúng nó phải có
cái gì nó khác nhau nó mới nằm ba chứ.
Đều hiển nhiên mà đúng không? Giống nhau
thì cùng đầu thì dễ quá rồi.
Các bạn nhìn ra có một vấn đề về mặt
logic.
Người Trung, người Hàn, người Nhật,
người Việt các nước khác nhau mà người
ta vẫn gộp vào Châu Á thôi đúng không?
gộp vào châu Á trong khi bốn ông trả lệ
bốn ông khác biệt nhau vẫn gộp vào châu
Á thôi. Đây đây
các bạn nhìn ra go này có vấn đề gì? Có
vấn đề về mặt logic. Có một vấn đề về
mặt logic.
Tất cả gì cần gợi ý mình để hết trên này
mình không thể gợi ý gì thêm. Gợi ý thêm
là hết rồi. Mọi từ nhìn kỹ xem. Tất cả
những gì cần gợi ý thì mình đã show hết
trên màn hình cho các bạn rồi. Gợi ý nữa
là hết chả có cái gì nữa.
Không nhìn ra vấn đề gì.
ngợi ý nữa là mình làm là mình làm luôn
rồi.
Tất cả những gì cần ý trên màn hình hết
nhá. Các bạn nhìn th hết tất cả những
thứ trên màn hình nhá. Mình để đây không
phải là để chơi đâu. Đấy là có lý do
đấy. Nhìn kỹ xem.
Nhìn kỹ xem mình gộp ba cái ông thiểu số
này lại nó có cái vấn đề gì ở đây.
Mình có một cái mô hình thứ hai chỉ tập
trung vào ba ông này thôi. Khổ quá. Mình
có một cái mô hình thứ hai nó chỉ tập
trung vào ba ông này thôi. Đúng không?
Mình vừa nói rồi đây là hyocal
classification đúng không? Mô hình thứ
hai nó chỉ có ăn ngủ với nó phân biệt ba
này thôi. Sao lại không phân biệt được?
Thì thì thì bây giờ nếu nếu nếu nó có
điểm chung thì người ta cần gì người ta
phân ra nữa đúng không các bạn không?
Tức [khịt mũi] là nó mà có điểm chung
thì thì thì
nó phải là thuộc về cùng một class sẵn
rồi đúng không?
Khi mà đã gộp với các class khác nhau nó
thì phải chấp nhận việc nó sẽ có cái
điểm khác nhau.
A đúng rồi, một bạn mình chả thấy
comment bao giờ nhưng lần này bạn
comment thì giá có giá trị.
Bạn Thịnh Anh nói đúng rồi. Nó giống như
này các bạn ạ. Các bạn cứ tưởng tượng
nhá. Bây giờ quần áo nhá. Được chưa? Nói
về quần áo nhá. Đ lại lớp mình cứ phải
đưa về ví dụ đúng không? XS,
S, M, L, XL. Được chưa? Năm cỡ cơ bản
đúng không? Extra, small, small, medium,
large, extra large được chưa? Thì bây
giờ nếu nếu mình gộp ông XS với cả S
hoàn toàn ok. Hai này gộp vào nhau mặc
dù chúng nó khác nhau hoặc gộp vào hoàn
toàn ok. Tại vì sao? Tại vì giữa chúng
chả có cái gì xen vào giữa cả, đúng
không? giữa chúng không có gì chen vào
giữa. Nhưng nếu các bạn nhét XS với XL
vào nhau ấy thì dưới góc nhìn của mô
hình nó sẽ không hiểu là cùng đây là
class gì đúng không? Trong cái này là có
cả những ông rất bé, có cả những ông rất
to m nhìn nó sẽ không hiểu đúng không?
Ví dụ chúng ta gộp người Hàn, người
Trung, người Nhật, người Việt Nam đi
đúng không? Rõ ràng giữa những cái này
nó vẫn có cái sự tương đồng và không có
gì chèn vào giữa nó. Các bạn không thể
lôi, các bạn không thể lôi một ông
Somali hoặc là một ông của Thổ, các bạn
không thể lôi một ông Somali hoặc là lôi
lôi một ông Ý. Các bạn chen vào giữa ông
Hàn ông Việt Nam nhặt được không chèn
vào được đúng không? Giữa những cái ông
mà các bạn gộp vào là Châu Á ấy những
cái ông khác châu Phi Châu Mỹ nó không
chèn vào giữa được đúng không? Đây n gọi
là gộp XS nó cũng chẳng có gì chèn vào
giữa được ok nhưng gộp XS đến XL giữa nó
có một đống như thế này. Được chưa? Thì
quay lại cái ví dụ của chúng ta
của chúng ta các bạn tô nhìn vào xem
đúng không? Cái ông SP là ông level thứ
hai đúng không? Trong khi hai ông còn
lại là một ông là level số 6 một ông là
số 7 đúng không? Ông số 6 với ông số 7
gộp nhau thì hoàn toàn ok. Tại vì giữa
chúng chả có cái gì cả. Nói chung nó là
liên tiếp nhau rồi. Các bạn gộp vào
thành một cái level tổng tốt hơn chả vấn
đề gì cả. Nhưng bây giờ gồm vào với cái
ông specialist này thì dưới góc nhìn của
mình nó sẽ không hiểu là cùng cái chob
này nó thuộc cái thể loại gì đúng không?
Vừa có những ông ít kinh nghiệm vừa có
nhiều kinh nghiệm đúng không? Thế nên ấy
cái hydrocular class cái hydrocular ấy
hydrocular phân phân tầng ấy nó sẽ có cả
hydracular classification và hydracular
clustering đúng không? Tức là nó áp dụng
cho cả bài toán phân loại và cả bài toán
hồi quy đều kiểu phân tầng như vậy.
Nhưng mà khi bạn phân tầng như vậy các
bạn phải đảm bảo gì? Là những cái ông
các bạn gộp vào ấy nó phải có một cái ý
nghĩa nó nó phải make sense. Nó phải
make sense chứ không phải là ví dụ các
bạn phân nhóm các bạn không phải các bạn
sẽ phân Việt Nam với cả Venezuia vào
cùng một nhóm tại vì nó có cùng chữ V.
Không phải như vậy đúng không? không
phải có một cái sự tương đồng gì về mặt
vị trí, về mặt địa trí địa lý, về mặt
văn hóa, về mặt ngôn ngữ lại phải phân
theo một cái logic ở đấy chứ không phải
là tôi cứ đấy thiểu số là tôi gộp vào
nhau đúng không phải như vậy. Thì ở đây
nó cũng thế thôi. Ba ông này đều là
thiểu số nhưng không phải cứ vì như vậy
các bạn nhắm nhắm mỗi các bạn gộp với
nhau đúng không? Ông sáu với ông 7 này
gộp thì được ông hai thì không gộp được
nhúng chưa?
Không phải là thứ tự. Tại vì sao? Ví dụ
người Hàn Trung Việt Nhật thì làm gì có
thứ tự đâu. Trong cái bài này thì nó là
thứ tự nhưng mà bài khác không có thứ
tự. Tức là cái việc đấy nó phải hợp lý.
Mình chỉ nói là hợp lý thôi. Trong
trường hợp này hợp lý về mặt thứ tự. Còn
trong trường hợp khác hợp lý nóể sự là
sự tương đồng giữa các class đúng không?
Các cái ông mà gộp với nhau nó phải có
sự tương đồng gì đấy đúng không? Về mặt
văn hóa, mặt cái gì đấy kiểu kiểu như
vậy được chưa? Nó phải nó phải hợp lý,
nó phải logic. Còn logic này nó là gì?
Thì tùy mỗi bài toàn nó sẽ có cái sự
logic khác nhau. Được chưa? Thế chứ
không phải chúng ta vì chúng ta cứ muốn
gộp là chúng ta gộp. Giống như là cái
lúc mà chúng ta các bạn thấy không?
Giống như kiểu lúc chúng ta các bạn nhớ
là lúc chúng ta mà xử lý cái cột
location á đây này. Đúng không? Chúng ta
chúng ta giảm bớt số lượng location bằng
cách gì chúng chỉ lấy cái mã mã bang
thôi. Nhưng mà do chúng ta dự cái lập
luận là gì? Tôi có thể lập luận là trong
cù một bang có thể là cái yêu cầu công
việc nó tương đương nhau thì tôi mới gộp
chứ không phải là vì tôi muốn gộp tôi cứ
sống chết tôi phải giảm đi. Không phải
như vậy đúng không?
Được chưa?
Rồi thế thôi. Thế với cái bộ tất nhiên
đấy là cái thứ chúng ta có thể làm. Còn
cái việc mà balance xong ấy nó có hay là
gộp xong ấy nó có giúp mô hình tốt hay
không? Chúng ta phải thử đúng không?
Không có gì đảm bảo cả. Không có gì đảm
bảo là chúng ta áp dụng cái tech này lại
giúp cho mô hình tốt hơn. Chúng ta phải
thử phải test thử được chưa?
Ok. Bạn có hỏi gì không?
Nghỉ ra 5 phút nhá.
5 phút nhá. Nào muốn thì các bạn cứ hỏi
nhá. Mình vẫn ngồi trước máy thôi chưa?
Vừa thấy mô hình này xong.
Hm. [khịt mũi]
H
Ok.
[âm nhạc]
Cần gì ngày mai đâu mình có thể nói luôn
theo mình nhá. Theo mình, theo mình ấy
thì bây giờ ấy nếu mà học về AI ấy, một
là những bạn nào mà các bạn đã có công
việc ở những cái mảng khác rồi, các bạn
học thì thấy là rất là ok, rất là c và
các bạn hãy học có thể học sẽ dễ hơn.
Cái khóa này thật ra không phải để thiết
kế cho những bạn đã đi làm rồi và các
bạn làm ở cái mảng khác. Cái khóa này nó
chỉ thiết kế cho bạn nào các bạn muốn
theo cái hướng là data scientist với cả
machining hoặc là AI engineer thôi. Đấy,
nhưng một cái thứ hai nữa mình nghĩ là
gì? Là bây giờ các bạn không nên để chỉ
học AI thuần. Học AI thuần rất là khó
xin việc. Các bạn nên là học AI để các
bạn áp dụng nó vào một cái mảng nào đấy.
Tức là ví dụ mà các bạn đang có học một
cái mảng là mảng điện đi hoặc là mảng
tài chính đi đúng không? Các bạn học AI
thì các bạn áp dụng vào cái mảng của bạn
rất là tốt, rất là tốt. Chứ còn nếu mà
chỉ đi theo AI thuần ấy thì mình nghĩ
rất là khó sinh việc. Ít nhất là ở Việt
Nam. Ít nhất là ở Việt Nam cái việc rất
là khó sinh việc. Ở nước ngoài thì còn
đỡ nhá. Ở nước ngoài còn đỡ. Ở nước
ngoài nó không có cái những cái món là
yêu cầu những người mới ra trường phải
có mấy năm kinh nghiệm đâu. Nó không có
cái đấy thì nó sẽ dễ hơn. Ở Việt Nam
mình thấy là nếu mà chỉ đi thuần ai thôi
ấy thì trừ khi các bạn rất là giỏi, các
bạn học ở những trường rất là tốt. Ví dụ
các bạn học ở bưu chính thông, các bạn
học ở Bách Khoa, các bạn học ở đạo quốc
gia hoặc là mấy m mấy cái trường nổi nổi
trong a trong trong Nam ấy. Đấy thì thì
còn ok còn không thì rất rất là khó, rất
là cạnh là cạnh cạnh tranh. Đấy thì mình
nghĩ là thế. Thường ngày xưa mình thì
học tuần AI hoàn toàn ok không vấn đề gì
cả. Thường ngày xưa mình nó ít cạnh ít
cạnh tranh nhưng bây giờ nó khác rồi nên
các bạn đi theo cái hướng này các bạn
học thêm bổ trợ một cái ngành nào đấy ví
dụ các bạn học sau ngành đi. Ví dụ một
các bạn học sau ngành hoặc là các bạn
đang học cái ngành khác các bạn học AI
để các bạn bổ trợ thì rất là tốt. Còn đi
thuần vào AI không thì mình nghĩ không
nên nó cạnh tranh quá.
làm công ty ngoài thì thường là sẽ phải
thường là sẽ phải
đi học lấy cái bằng trước bằng Việt Nam
chúng ta nó là kể cả ví dụ như ngày xưa
h mình đi Đức chẳng hạn cái bằng Bách
Khoa mình sang kia nó chỉ đúng là một tờ
A4 nó không có một cái tác dụng gì cả
tức là tức là tại vì chúng ta không phải
đến từ Hàn từ Nhật những cái nước mà
được kiểu hoặc là chúng ta không phải
những cái trường top ở ở Trung Quốc
chúng ta đến từ Việt Nam Việt Nam mông
cổ về m nước ở châu Phi cái bằng chúng
ta đem đi ra ngoài không phải là không
phải là mình đi không phải là mình từng
làm ở nước ngoài nên mình chê B Việt Nam
đâu nhưng mà thực là cái bằng người ta
mình cũng bằng bách B Bách Khoa mà cũng
ở Việt Nam cũng là một cái bằng có giá
trị đôi nhưng mà ra ngoài nó nó chả có
tác dụng gì cả. Chúng ta các bạn cũng có
thể các bạn xin tức là nó vẫn có những
người ta xin được việc nhưng mà nó rất
là khó nó rất rất là khó trừ đấy nó rất
là cá biệt rất là nó nó chính là outlier
luôn ấy thường chúng ta vẫn phải qua cái
bước chúng ta đi học đã
đi học nó tốt. Tại vì sao? Tại vì nó
giúp các bạn cái các bạn đi học 2 năm
học master ở nước ngoài nó sẽ giúp các
bạn để các bạn làm quen với cái môi
trường đấy. Môi môi trường làm việc mới
thì môi trường làm việc ở Việt Nam với
nước ngoài rất là khác nhau. Các bạn mà
đồ một phát các bạn đang ở Việt Nam các
bạn nước ngoài nó nhiều nhiều khi nó
mình nghĩ là nó sẽ bị ngược mình nghĩ là
có thể ăn đ học thì nó vẫn coi như là
vừa học kiến thức của mình vừa có cái
trải nghiệm cái văn hóa mới.
Tiếp nhá tiếp nhá. Rồi các bạn thấy
chưa? sẽ ra chúng ta xong cái phần liên
quan đến bài toán
bài toán ờ classification cho mảng NLP
rồi đúng không?
Mảng LP như mình nói tức là khi mà chúng
ta học về AI nhá thường các bạn sẽ bắt
đầu học về data machining là cái khóa
này là tập trung chúng ta sẽ hay làm
việc với rượu có cấu trúc ví dụ như là
file dượu dọc bản chẳng hạn file Excel
file CSV kiểu kiểu như vậy và thậm chí
là file Jason cũng là một kiểu rượu có
cấu trúc đấy nhưng mà cái kiểu rượu cấu
trúc này không phải là cái dự không phải
là cái loại duy nhất người ta còn cái
loại phức tạp hơn dượu dạng văn bản cái
bộ job này nó chính là một cái dạng dạng
văn bản này được chưa ăn bản này mạng
thường trong mảng np và cái thứ hai nữa
là ví dụ mảng mảng mảng mảng mảng thứ
hay là mảng computer vision. Đấy, với
NLP và computer vision thì thường ta sẽ
dùng các cái tô toán trong deep learning
là những cái thứ của khóa sau học. Còn đ
toán trong machine này thì áp dụng cho
một vài bài toán đơn giản thì vẫn được
nhưng mà thường ta sẽ không có áp dụng.
Thế hôm nay chúng ta sẽ thử chúng ta sẽ
cùng nhau làm quen bây giờ cái nửa buổi
cuối này chúng ta sẽ làm quen với mảng
computer vision chúng ta sẽ thử nhau xây
dựng cái mô hình machining cho bài toán
computer vision mà xem nó hiệu quả như
thế nào. Chúng ta nói việc là vì sao
trong compation thường người ta sẽ ưu
tiên là dùng deep learning nhiều hơn là
machining nhá.
Đầu tiên cả lớp cho mình hỏi này. Bây
giờ mình có một một cái tên như này.
Em này mình có một cái tên này mình gõ đ
ở đ chã này. Memnis. Bạn nào đã từng
nghe cái tên này rồi cho mình số một.
Bạn nào đây lần đầu bạn thấy cho mình số
0. Từng nghe từng biết đến nó rồi cho
mình số 1. Chưa nghe bao giờ. Lần đầu
tiên nghe thấy nó cho mình số 0
nhá. Với những bạn nào mà các bạn học về
cái mảng gọi là mảng deep learning for
computeration đấy mới là mảng cái mảng
chuyên của mình. Cái mảng mà mình thuận
tay nhất, cái mảng mà mình tự tin nhất
và cái mảng làm việc chính của mình là
mảng diing for computer vision chứ không
phải machining. Nhưng cái mình dọ dạy
các bạn trong khóa này là hầu hết nó đến
từ cái theo mình đi mình mình đi làm.
Ngày xưa trên trường mình học về deep
learning.
Thế thì trong deeping computation có một
cái bộ rượu gọi là bộ rượu vỡ lòng luôn.
Bộ Hello W luôn là cái bộ emnis. Đây bộ
em như này
nh nói qua nhá. Cái bộ này là một cái bộ
rượu của những cái bảng số viết tay nó
nó như này này. Đây nó như này. Đấy.
Toàn số người ta vẽ tay mỗi một cái số
các bạn nhìn đây nó là một một cái ảnh.
Được chưa? Cái bộit này nó có hai bộ là
bộ trê với cả bộ test. Bộ trê là có
60.000 này. Còn bộ test là có 10.000
thôi. Thì với bộ nào thì nó cũng sẽ có
đủ các cái số từ 0 đến 9. Nó có nó có đủ
10 class mà đúng không? Nó có đủ 10
class chưa? Nó đủ từ 0 đến 9 luôn. Đấy.
Được chưa? Nó có 10 class. Thế thì
với bộ trin là 60.000. Tức là với bộ
trin ấy thì mỗi class nó sẽ có xấp xỉ là
6000 này. Và với bộ test nó có 10.000
thì mỗi nó sẽ xấp xỉ là 1000. Được chưa?
Nó sẽ không đúng là 6000 đến 1000 đâu.
Sẽ có ví dụ bộ chuên có cái ông mà sẽ có
khoảng 5900 bao nhiêu ông 60 bao nhiêu
nó nó thừa thẹo một tí. Thế nhưng mà tóm
lại là xấp xỉ như vậy. Nó xấp xỉ như
vậy. Đấy. Mỗi cái ảnh này đều là ảnh đen
trắng. Đều là ảnh đen trắng. Ờ kích
thước của ảnh đều là 28 x 28 pixel, rất
là bé thôi. 28 x 28 nó bé này đây. Nó
như này đây. Nó bé như này đây. Nó nó
kiểu như này đây là ảnh được chuẩn hóa
rồi. Ờ
các bạn chú ý nhá. Mình sẽ nói về cái
này mua cái xe nhìn nó dễ hiểu hơn nhỉ.
À đây ông này được đây ông này được.
Các bạn nhìn nhá.
Các bạn nhìn này, những cái ảnh đen
trắng á, các bạn nhìn nghe kỹ nhá. Ờ ảnh
nó sẽ các bạn khi các bạn x bạn nào các
bạn đi vào mảng computer vision giống
như mình, các bạn sẽ làm việc với rất
nhiều loại ảnh khác nhau. Nhưng mà trong
đó thì có hai loại ảnh chính. Một là ảnh
tiếng Việt mình hay gọi là ảnh đen trắng
còn tiếng Anh người ta gọi là ảnh thang
màu xám. Greay scare image. Được chưa?
Greay scare image là cái ảnh như này.
Đấy. Ảnh này chúng ta hay gọi ảnh đen
trắng. Thật ra nó không phải nó chỉ có
đen với trắng đâu. Nó còn có rất nhiều
màu khác nhưng mà nó chỉ màu long canh
nó chỉ kiểu xám xịt này thôi. Được chưa?
Ảnh này gọi là ảnh đen trắng tiếng Việt
mình hoặc làọ way scare trong tiếng Anh.
Còn ảnh thứ hai là gọi là ảnh màu người
ta gọi là ảnh AGB red blue. Thế nói về
cái ảnh đen trắng trước đi. Cái ảnh đen
trắng này về mặt bản chất nó là một cái
mảng hai chiều. Và mảng hai chiều trong
toán người ta gọi nó là một cái gì các
bạn? Là một cái ma trận. Được chưa? Cái
ma trận là một cái mảng hai chiều. Được
chưa? Thế thì cái mảng hai chiều này ấ
một cái bức ảnh các bạn biết là một bức
ảnh người ta được tạo ra bởi rất nhiều
cái pixel đúng không? pixel.
Ví dụ người ta nói là một cái ảnh full
HD đi. Một cái ảnh full HD là một cái
ảnh mà có chiều ngang là 1920 pixel và
chiều cao là 1080 đúng không? 1920 nh
1080 thì đấy gọi là ảnh full HD là ảnh
pixel à tức là full HD 1920 nh 1080
pixel. Được chưa? Đấy thì mỗi một mỗi
một cái pixel là cái gì? Mỗi một pixel
nó nó là một cái đơn vị nguyên tử để tạo
ra bức ảnh. Thế nào được gọi là đơn vị
nguyên tử? Đơn vị nguyên tử có nghĩa là
nghĩa làm sao các bạn? Thế nào được gọi
là đơn vị nguyên tử các bạn?
Đơn vị nguyên tử là đơn vị mà nó làm sao
nó không chia được nữa. Đúng rồi, chính
xác không chia nhỏ hơn được nữa. Đúng
không? Đơn thị nguyên tử nó không chia
nhỏ hơn nữa. Sau này các bạn học về các
bạn sẽ biết là trong cái một ngôn ngữ
lớn ấy người ta sẽ gọi đơn vị nguyên tử.
Người ta gọi là cái gì? Người ta gọi là
cái thứ mà các bạn hay gọi ấy. Người ta
gọi là
trong đơn vị nguyên tử nó là gì? Nó
không phải là word. Nó không phải là từ
trong token chính xác chúng ta nói token
không không bit thì là bit không phải
bit b là của nói về số rồi hay là token
đúng không trong token nó không phải là
một word đâu. Token thậm chí nó còn nhỏ
hơn 1 word cơ nhá. Thế nói với lại về
ảnh chúng ta thấy một cái ảnh như thế
đúng không các bạn xem một cái ảnh nó nó
có bao nhiêu bito chiều ngang bao nhiêu
phi chiều cao được chưa?
Thông thường á, thông thường tức là tức
là bây giờ ấy tôi có một cái ảnh mình
đang gọi tạp là ảnh đen trắng thì th mà
thật ra tên đen trắng nó không đúng
nhưng mà thôi tiếng Việt mình hay gọi
ảnh đen trắng đúng không? Tôi có một cái
bảnh đen trắng này đúng không? Tôi muốn
lưu chữ nó trong máy tính á tôi muốn lưu
chữ một cái ảnh đen trắng trong máy tính
đấy tôi sẽ cần phải dùng một cái mảng
hai chiều hay nói khác là tôi dùng một
cái ma trận đúng không? Tôi dùng cái ma
trận tôi mới lưu chữ được.
Thế thì ờ
bình thường khi chúng ta nói về kích
thước của một cái ảnh, chúng ta sẽ nói
về hoặc chúng ta nói về cái độ phân giải
của một cái màn hình, chúng ta sẽ nói về
chiều ngang trước với chiều cao sau đúng
không? Một cái ảnh full HD là một cái
ảnh 1920 nh 1080, 1920 là chiều ngang,
1080 là chiều cao. Thế nhưng mà tuy
nhiên khi chúng ta nói về kích thước của
một cái ma trận hoặc là của một cái bảng
hai chiều lưu trữ một cái ảnh á, chúng
ta sẽ phải nói ngược lại. Chúng ta sẽ
phải nói về chiều cao trước, chiều ngang
sau. Tức là gì? Ví dụ một cái ảnh full
HD mà tôi lưu trong máy, tôi sẽ cần một
cái mảng có kí thức là 1080 nh 1920.
Vì sao tôi lại phải đảo như vậy?
Vì sao tôi lại phải đảo như vậy? Khi nói
về kích thước của cái ma trận hoặc là
cái mảng hai chiều lưu trước một cái ảnh
đen trắng, tôi lại phải nói về chiều cao
trước, chiều ngang sau.
Lý do là vì sao?
Tại vì
tại vì mảng hai chiều hay là ma trận
đúng không? Khi mà các bạn ngày xưa các
bạn học môn đại số hoặc là môn đại số
tuyến tính các bạn biết rồi đúng không?
Khi nói về kích thước của một cái ma
trận ta sẽ bao giờ chúng ta cũng phải
nói về đúng rồi số hàng trước số cột
xong chính xác đúng không? Khi nói về
kích thước của một cái ma trận bao giờ
cũng phải nói về số hàng trước và số cột
sau chứ không nói ngược lại được đúng
không? Mà số hàng nó lại đại diện cho
chiều cao, số cột đại diện cho chiều
ngang. Thấy chưa? Thì các bạn thấy là
gì? Tức là cách chúng ta nói trong
camion nó sẽ ngược lại so với người ở
ngoài người ta nói đúng không? Người ta
nói một cái ảnh full HD người ta hiểu là
1920 1080 nhưng các bạn phải hiểu là gì?
Là khi mà tôi lưu chữ nó trong máy ấy
tôi sẽ gần một cái mảng có kích thước là
1080 nhân 1920 đúng không? Thế ok. Và
với ảnh đen trắng á với ảnh gr scare á
thì mỗi một cái pixel sẽ là một cái giá
trị nằm từ 0 cho đến 255. Màu 0 à giá
trị 0 là đen hoàn toàn, 255 là trắng
hoàn toàn. Còn những cái màu ở giữa ví
dụ màu xám các bạn nhỉ. Đây màu xám này
sẽ ở giữa sữa này độ 160. Được chưa? Thế
nên vẫn mình bảo các bạn ấy là chúng ta
t chúng ta gọi ảnh đen trắng không phải
như vậy. Đây không phải ảnh đen trắng
này nó còn có nhiều màu khác nữa ngoài
đen với trắng đúng không? Nó có đến 256
màu cơ chẳng qua những cái màu này nó cứ
xám xám thì chúng ta cứ gọi quen ảnh lên
đen trắng được chưa? Ông nào mà càng gần
không thì càng đen mà càng gần 250 thì
càng trắng đâ đây qu số đây cái ông giá
trị bằng 5 này nó rất là đen ông 2 bốn
mấy nó rất là trắng chưa
đấy thì đây là cái bộ này nó sẽ có hai
bộ truyên và bộ test bộ truyên là có
60.000 ảnh bộ test là có 10.000 Hình ảnh
thôi. Đấy, bộ trin thì 10 class một
class 6000 còn bộ test là 10 class một
class 1000 thì thôi.
Được chưa?
Đấy. Thế bây giờ cái bộ này thì ra người
ta đã upload rất nhiều có rất nhiều cách
để download này. Đây là bộ rất là phổ
biến. Đây là bộ như là bộ vỡ lòng. Đấy.
Thế thì bây giờ mình sẽ mình có cái bộ
này. Bây giờ mình sẽ thử vừa chúng ta
vừa nói về bài toán phân loại phân loại
các cái job đúng không? Là bài toán
trong mảng NLP. Bài toán phân loại trong
mảnh NP là bài toán cơ bản nhất trong
mảng NLP. Thì trong bảng cameration bài
toán phân loại ảnh hay là image
classification cũng là bài toán cơ bản
nhất thì bây giờ cũng sẽ áp dụng y
nguyên thôi. Được chưa? Ờ
đúng không? Thì bây giờ nhiệm vụ tôi vẫn
thế. Thì bây giờ ấy với cái bộ với cái
bộ này chúng ta sẽ có phải có một cái
file nó có nhiều thật thật ra thì trên
mạng nó có nhiều nó có nhiều file lắm
nhưng mà đây mình sẽ chia sẻ các bạn một
cái file như này. Một cái file này các
bạn có thể các bạn đâu ấy nhỉ?
Đây cái file này là một cái file nó là
một cái file đi dạng của 5 nó nặng
khoảng 11 m đây nhá. Mình up cho các bạn
ở đây. Được chưa? Các bạn down cái file
này về chưa? Các bạn down file này về.
Sau đó thì mình chúng ta sẽ chúng ta sẽ
thử cùng nhau xây dựng một cái mô hình
phân loại xem được chưa? Mô hình nó sẽ
rất là ngắn thôi. Cái này code sẽ là
ngắn thôi. Nó sẽ đơn giản hơn cái bài NP
vừa rất là nhiều đây nhá. Mình gọi là
image classification nhá. Được chưa?
image classification này. Thế thì cái
file mà mình vừa gửi cho các bạn ấy nó
có nó có cái đuôi là NPZ. Đây cái file
nó đuôi là đây này NPZ này. Được chưa?
Đây là một cái định dạng riêng biệt của
Np.
Cái định dạng này chuyên giúp các bạn
lưu chữ các cái mảng cho Nie. Đấy được
chưa? Thế bây giờ muốn đọc nó thì phải
dùng np import 5 SNP nhá. Đầu tiên như
này này. Đúng không? Sa mình sẽ đọc này.
Đọc này. Withd này n.load load này. Load
đường dẫn này ra.npz
nhá. Được chưa?
S
S S S S này được chưa? Mình sẽ đọc rượu
vào này.
Đáng nhẽ là chúng phải AI nó gợi ý sẵn
rồi.
Đây nó sẽ có thêm một cái dòng ở dưới
nữa.
Đáng nhẽ để mình định cho các bạn phân
tích từng bước nhưng mà mình tắt AI rồi.
Mình tắt cả cái công cụ AI rồi mà nó vẫn
lòi ra cái này. Cái này là cái phần mà
tự gợi ý mình mình cũng chịu chả biết
tắt như nào. Ờ close rồi mấy cái mấy cái
agent khác cố đ các thứ mình tắt hết
rồi. Cái này chịu chả biết tất như nào.
X test Y test đây đúng không ạ? X test
đây. Được chưa? E test này. Đ thử nhá.
Này các bạn nhìn này. Nãy bạn thấy đẹp
chưa? Đây bộ trây. Bộ test đây.
Được chưa?
Trên phải test như này.
Trên đây. Test đây.
Đấy. Đây là các đây là nó phân chia sẵn
cho chúng ta luôn. Chúng ta còn chả phải
mở ra đúng không? Ờ ví dụ mình muốn biết
là cái distribution giữ d liệu mình
exchange chấm
value
như này nhá.
À ở value C là của kia
đây từ từ 5 P có n có ha n how
to
unique value. Nó có hàm 5 đây. Un c un c
n ch
un count. Đây được chưa?
trên được chưa?
Đây nhìn nhá.
Class số 0. Class số 0 thì có 5900 ảnh.
Số 1 thì có 600, số 2, số 3, số 4. Thế
vậy ông nó không phải 6000 hoàn toàn mà
mỗi ông lệch nhau một tí đúng không? Ông
thì trên ông thì dưới ông thò ra thụt
vào. Được chưa? Đấy. Thôi rồi. Anyway.
Exchange X Y X Y
không này.
Được chưa? Thế bây gi các bạn nhìn này.
Thế bây giờ bình thường là các bạn phải
tách dữ liệu và đây các bạn chả phải
tách nữa. Nó tách hộ các bạn sẵn luôn
rồi đúng không? Thế bây giờ bước theo
chúng ta làm cái gì bây giờ? Bây giờ
chúng ta muốn sử dụng cái mô hình để
phân loại phân loại các cái số này về 10
class khác nhau. Thế bây giờ bước thế ra
mình làm cái gì bây giờ?
Bây giờ mình làm cái gì bây giờ?
Làm cái gì đây?
Thử nghĩ xem làm gì tiếp bây giờ.
Bước tiếp theo cho làm gì tiếp bây giờ?
Bước tiếp theo chúng ta làm gì tiếp bây
giờ?
Làm gì đây?
Làm gì bây giờ các bạn?
Mỗi này xong rồi. Phân rượu xong là là
xong.
Cái này thôi hả các bạn?
Hay hết rồi.
Dễ thế này thôi.
Đây là hết rồi. Xong bài toán phân loại
rồi.
Nếu thế thì
nếu bây giờ chúng ta chuyển sang bài
toán tiếp theo nhá. Xong bài toán time c
forcasting nhá. Đúng không? Xong bài
toán phân loại rồi. Tức là xong rồi. Đây
t mình up đúng cái đoạn script này lên
nhá. là xong. Được chưa? Thì bây giờ
thế bây giờ bài toán tiếp theo đúng
không? Bây gi chúng ta nói xong về NLP
rồi. Nói xong về computer vision rồi.
Bài toán tiếp theo là bài toán gì? Là
bài toán time c forecasting. Được chưa?
Hôm nọ chúng ta mới học đến đây được
chưa? Chúng mới học đến đây được chưa?
Bây giờ chúng ta sẽ nói về bài toán time
c forcasting.
Các bạn chú ý này, cái bài toán cái bài
toán time c forcasting ấy thì thật ra nó
là trong bạn nào mà các bạn theo cái
mảng data ấy nó sẽ là một cái bài toán
mà nó
rất là phổ biến. Tại vì sao? Tại vì
thông thường nhá, thông thường ấy khi mà
chúng ta lưu trữ dữ liệu về một đối
tượng, chúng ta sẽ có cái xuống là chúng
ta sẽ lưu trữ thông tin này trong một
khoảng thời gian. Trong một khoảng thời
gian tức là gì? Tức là ví dụ bây giờ các
bạn theo dõi một người một người, một
người bệnh đi đúng không? Thì các bạn sẽ
cần phải theo dõi xem là cái người bệnh
này cái quá trình họ quá trình họ điều
trị mỗi ngày các cái giá trị họ như nào
đúng không? Ví dụ các bạn thấy là cái bộ
DBT ấ cái bộ DBT của chúng ta làm hôm nọ
ấy nó chỉ là cái thông tin về bệnh nhân
ấy tại một thời điểm cụ thể đúng không?
Thế nhưng mà [khịt mũi]
thế nhưng mà ví dụ nó theo dõi người ta
trong thực tế chúng ta sẽ theo dõi trong
một khoảng thời gian kiểu kiểu như vậy
đúng không? Hoặc chúng ta theo dõi điểm
của một chúng ta theo chúng ta theo dõi
cái việc là cái điểm của một sinh viên
chúng ta sẽ quay sau cả quá trình đúng
không? Tức là kỳ 1, kỳ 2, năm 1, 52 vân
vân. Chứ chúng ta ít khi chúng ta chỉ
đánh giá nó dựa vào đúng một thời điểm
cụ thể đúng không? Thế hoặc là bây giờ
các bạn các bạn các bạn tưởng tượng là
bây giờ các bạn mà sử dụng cái mô hình
để làm sao có thể
các bạn sử dụng cái mô hình để làm sao
để có thể ờ
các bạn ừ
muốn dự đoán cái doanh số doanh thu của
công ty trong tháng sau chẳng hạn đúng
không? Thì bây giờ khi mà các bạn muốn
dự đoán doanh thu cửa tháng sau ấy, các
bạn có thể dựa vào doanh thu cửa một vài
tháng gần đây đúng không? Tức là gì? Tức
là bây giờ ấy tôi khi mà tôi muốn đưa
một cái dự án trong tương lai ấy thì tôi
sẽ dựa vào những cái thông tin đã xảy ra
trong một khoảng thời ă trong quá khứ.
Hoặc bây gi các bạn muốn sử dụng cái mô
hình để làm sao có thể dự đoán được
nhiệt độ ngoài trời của hôm sau chẳng
hạn đúng không? thì các bạn sẽ dựa vào
nhiệt độ ngày trời của 7 hôm 10 rồi ví
dụ như vậy thì tất cả những cái chỗ
những những cái ví dụ này đều là ví dụ
của bài toán time series forecasting hay
là bài toán dự đoán chỗi thời gian đúng
không? Bài toán dán chút thời gian. Đây
là một bài toán có rất nhiều ứng dụng
trong thực tế. Đây là rất nhiều ứng dụng
trong thực tế. Và thường bạn nào các bạn
làm data scientist các bạn rất hay làm
việc với bài về bài toán này. Ví dụ như
là công ty của mình ngày xưa bọn mình là
một công ty về mảng game mobile thì bọn
mình có một cái bài toán làm sao tôi có
thể tôi dự đoán doanh tôi có thể dự đoán
doanh số doanh thu của một tức là công
ty mình làm rất nhiều game. Mỗi một tuần
mỗi một tháng mình sẽ ra một cái game
mới và khi ra một cái game ấy bởi vì
công ty mình là toàn những game kiểu me
liền. Mi alien tức là game ra 1 2 tháng
nó chết thì thôi cũng chả quan tâm. Đấy.
Thế nhưng mà
thế nhưng mà mà tức là khi mà mình ra
một cái game bọn mình sẽ phải chạy quảng
cáo chạy quảng cáo cho nó đúng không?
Tại vì nếu không chạy quảng cáo thì chả
ai biết game đấy cả. Nó chạy quảng cáo
thì các bạn phải bỏ chi phí ra. Thì khi
chạy chạy quảng cáo như vậy tôi chạy
quảng cáo trong 1 hai ngày tôi phải dự
án được trước xem là tôi phải dự án
trước được xem là là
trong một tuần tới liệu tôi sẽ kiếm được
lại bao nhiêu đúng không? Kiểu kiểu như
vậy tức tỏ
vào đ tôi bỏ đầu vào tôi dự vào những
cái thông tin tôi thu thập được từ những
ngày đầu tiên tôi phải dẫn xem những
ngày tiếp theo đ số lượng người chơi là
bao nhiêu. Ví dụ như vậy đấy cũng là cái
ví dụ về đán tram forecasting đúng
không? T gì tôi sẽ dự đoán những cái giá
trị xảy ra trong tương lai dựa vào những
cái thứ liên tiếp nhau đã xảy ra trong
quá khứ. Được chưa?
Thế thì về cái dữ liệu của bài toán C
forcasting ấy được chưa? thì nó có
thường người ta sẽ hay trình bày nó dạng
là dạng bảng này. Thi thoảng các bạn
cũng sẽ thấy dình bày dạng file cason
nhưng mà dạng bảng là dạng phổ biến
nhất. Được chưa? Dạng bảng là dạng phổ
biến nhất.
Thế thì với dữ liệu dạng bảng ấy thì nó
lại nó lại nó lại
nó lại có nhiều kiểu. Tức là các bạn
nhìn nhá. V đây mình cho các bạn xem một
vài cái ví dụ này. Có những cái bộ dữ
liệu ấy thì cái dệu dạng C nó sẽ nằm
theo từng hàng nhưng lại có những bộ nó
đã nằm theo từng cột. Các bạn nhìn nhá.
Ví dụ với cái bộ dượu đầu tiên ngoài cột
bên trái này các bạn thấy không? Các bạn
nhìn nhá chúng ta sẽ có một chúng ta sẽ
có nguyên một cái cột đây. Cột này là
cột về về gọi là về cái time stamp về
nhãn thời gian. Tim stamp nhãn thời gian
các bạn thấy không? Ngày mùng 01 tháng
năm 2020 này 1 tháng 1 tháng 3 tức đây
là cách nhau 1 tháng một được chưa? Cách
nhau cứ 1 tháng 1 1 tháng 1 1 tháng 1
được chưa? mấy cái cột còn lại nó là
những cái thông tin gì đó đúng không?
Chả biết nó về cái gì mà tốm lại đây là
một cái ví dụ về dữ liệu nhãn thời gian
đúng không? Thì các bạn thấy là nguyên
cái cột đầu tiên nó là dành cho cái nhãn
thời gian. Cái bộ rượu thứ hai này
nguyên cái hàng đầu tiên dành dành cho
thời gian này đúng không? Ờ tháng 1 2017
tháng 2 2017 tháng 3 2017 tháng 4 2017
vân vân vân vân đúng không mỗi đúng
không? Mỗi một hàng là một cái store tôi
cũng chả biết nó là cái gì. Có thể nó là
nó là các cái chuỗi cửa hàng của một cái
dòng sản phẩm gì đấy của một cái hãng gì
đấy đúng không? Ví dụ hãng này nó có 14
chỗi cửa hàng thì ví dụ đây có thể là
cái bộ dữ liệu độ về doanh số là doanh
thu của nó trong vòng 1 năm chẳng hạn.
Ví dụ như vậy được chưa?
Thế doanh số là doanh thu trong 1 năm
đấy. Hoặc là nó có thể các bạn và các
chú ý này. Không phải lúc nào ấy với dự
dạng cch đều đâu nhá. Không phải lúc nào
dược đoạn time nó cũng cách đều mà nó có
thể nó sẽ nó sẽ nó sẽ cách ngắt quãng.
Tức là gì? thì tức là có thể là mấy cột
đầu cách nhau một tháng sau lại cách
nhau một quý chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như vậy
mặc dù cái kiểu cách không đều này nó
cũng ít phổ biến hơn nhưng mà không phải
là không thể được chưa? Hoặc bạn thấy nó
có thể cách đập ký nó khác cách này nó
thập kỷ này đây này đúng không? Cái bộ
rượu ở dưới này đúng không? Mỗi một cột
đúng không? 90 này population 1990 2000
này 2010 này đúng không? Cái lượng thay
đổi sân số từ 80 đến 90 từ 90 đến 2000
này đấy chưa? Có rất nhiều kiểu khác
nhau đúng không? Các bạn thấy là nó cũng
là dạng bảng nhưng mà cái kiểu dạng bảng
này nó không đưa ngay vào trong mô hình
machining được. Ví dụ ví dụ đâu nhở? Ví
dụ là
đây đúng không? Ví dụ trong cái bài về
bộ DBT ấy thì nguyên cái bảng rượu ban
đầu ấy các bạn có thể nhét ngay vào mô
hình được nhưng mà cái rượu này các bạn
không đưa ngay vào mô hình được. Tại vì
sao? Tại vì ví dụ nhá. Ví dụ với cái bộ
rượu góc trung qu bên phải đi. Bộ rượu
thứ hai đi đúng không? Giả sử bây giờ
các bạn muốn sử dụng cái mô hình để làm
sao mà dựa vào doanh xu doanh số doanh
thu của 6 tháng liên tiếp để dự đoán
những cái tháng tiếp theo chẳng hạn đúng
không? Tức là gì? Tức là input là data
của 6 tháng liên tiếp và output là của
một hoặ là của 2 tháng tiếp theo đúng
không? Thế thì các bạn nhìn thấy xem đây
là cái bộ rượu nó có đến 12 cột 12 tháng
này bây giến 6 tháng thôi. Tôi lấy kiểu
gì bây giờ? Sao để tôi sẻ riêng 6 tháng
bây giờ đúng không? Thế nên là cái dự
này các bạn sẽ không có đưa vào mô hình
ngay được. Được chưa?
Chúng ta sẽ phải có cách chúng ta xử lý
được chưa? Phải có cách chúng ta xử lý.
Thế thì thế đây đây là những cái đầu
tiên những cái cơ bản nhất chúng ta cần
biết về bài toán time ser forcasting.
Được chưa? Có nào câu hỏi gì không?
Có ai có thắc mắc gì không?
Tiếp nhá. Thế ờ các bạn chú ý này, với
cái dự đoạn time ấy, cái
đơn vị tức là từng cái entry, từng cái
từng cái sample một ấy nó có thể nó rất
là đa dạng. Nó có thể nó dẫn cái thời
gian có thể là kiểu là ngày này, tháng
này, năm này hoặc là ngày tháng năm hoặc
là giờ này, phút giây hoặc là giờ phút
giây có cả mizây nữa. Thậm chí nó có thể
chia theo quý, chia theo thập kỷ, chia
theo thế kỷ. Tức nó có rất nhiều dạng đa
dạng khác nhau không nhãn thời gian
thôi. Kiểu như vậy đấy. Ví dụ mấy hai
cái bộ đầu tiên ở đây các bạn nó chơ
từng tháng một cái bộ dưới nó còn chơ
hẳn thập kỷ cơ đúng không? Thế mà thông
thường ví dụ các bạn có rượu công ty thì
có thể các bạn sẽ chia theo kiểu là từng
giờ nó cứ 1 giờ các bạn record một lần.
Do đây cái rượu bài thật nó cực kỳ phổ
biến luôn với bệnh là làm data
scientist.
Thế bây giờ các bạn nhìn nhá. Thế bây
giờ dữ liệu nó như thế này. Được chưa?
dữ liệu nó đang như thế này đúng không?
Hóa bên các bạn có một cái bộ dữ liệu
các bạn có nhiệt độ ngoài trời trong
vòng 1 năm chẳng hạn. Tức là các bạn sẽ
có
ví dụ là nhiệt độ ngoài trời 1 năm ở 20
địa điểm đi thì các bạn sẽ có 20 hàng
mỗi hàng tương với một địa điểm các bạn
sẽ có 365 cột đúng không? Thì bây giờ
các bạn muốn sử dụng cái mô hình để làm
sao? Tôi có thể tôi dựa vào nhiệt độ
ngoài trời của 7 hôm để tôi dự đán hôm
thứ thứ không thứ tám chẳng hạn. Thì bây
giờ tôi sẽ phải biến đổi dữ liệu kiểu
gì? Bây giờ dữ liệu để nguyên này
không đưa được vào mô hình đúng không?
Mô hình tôi chỉ muốn dựa vào
nhiệt độ ngoài trời của 6 hôm để tôi dự
án hôm tiếp theo thôi. Nhưng mà bộ rượu
tôi lại cho tôi tận đến 365 hôm cơ. Tôi
làm thế nào bây giờ?
Làm thế nào bây giờ để nguyên dụ đây
đúng không? cái bộ rượu đạnh thế thôi.
Tôi muốn xây dựng cái mô hình để dựa vào
doanh số của 6 tháng liên tiếp để tôi dự
án tháng thứ bảy.
Thế nhưng mà tại đây tôi lại có những 12
tháng tôi làm thế nào bây giờ?
Sao mỗi 6 tháng á? Ờ không cái này không
ổn à?
Tôi có một cái bộ rượu nó nó cho tôi đến
12 tháng nhưng mà tôi chỉ muốn rượu một
cái mô hình dựa vào 6 tháng để tháng thứ
bảy thôi. Tôi làm thế nào bây giờ?
Split. Đúng rồi, split. Nhưng mà tại vì
6 tháng thì split thì nó chẵn. Thì ví dụ
bây giờ tôi chỉ muốn tôi dựa vào 5 tháng
đi. Tôi muốn mô hình dựa vào 5 tháng thì
tôi đán tháng thứ sáu. Thế thì 12 không
chia cho 5 thì tôi split kiểu gì?
chia hết cho 5 split kiểu gì?
Nhưng mà chia nó sẽ không đều.
5 tháng đầu 5 tháng sau thôi. Còn chừa
là 2 tháng cuối. 2 tháng cuối nhét đi
đâu bây giờ
đúng không? 5 tháng. 5 tháng đúng không?
12 không chia cho 5 chia khoảng 5 52 hai
thằng cuối vẫn đi đâu bây giờ?
người ta sẽ không chia một cách riêng
biệt mà người ta sẽ chia theo các khoảng
trống lấn nhau. Này các bạn nhìn đây mô
tả đây tức là gì? Tôi sẽ xây dựng một
cái cửa sổ người ta gọi là cửa sổ trượt
hay là sliding window đúng không?
Sliding window là cái cửa sổ trượt. Ví
dụ tôi đang có thông tin nhiệt độ ngoài
trời của 10 hôm liên tiếp. Bây giờ tôi
muốn xây dựng một cái mô hình để làm sao
có thể dựa vào nhiệt độ ngoài trời của
năm hôm dự đoán được cái hôm thứ sáu.
Được chưa? Tôi muốn sử dụng cái mô hình
dự ngoài trời của 5 hôm để dự đoán được
hôm thứ sáu.
Đấy. Thế thì
tôi sẽ có một cái cửa sổ tôi sẽ có sáu
giá trị đúng không? Tôi cứ búc sáu giá
trị ra tôi lấy năm ông cho phần trên và
một ông cho phần test. Tôi dịch tiếp như
vậy thôi. Được chưa? Animation này được
chưa? Tôi cứ dịch cử sổ cứ một 1 một ông
tôi cứ lấy sáu ông. năm ông đầu tôi
thành train ông cuối cho hành test là
xong được chưa đấy đây là kiểu để chúng
ta có thể tức là dữ liệu ban đầu là dữ
liệu dạng bảng dữ liệu sau cũng là dảng
nhưng mà cái dạng sau mới là cái dạng
các bạn có thể đưa vào trong mô hình
đúng không dạng đầu thì các bạn không
đưa được chưa ngoài ra thì nếu chúng ta
có thêm những cái thông tin thêm mà nó
có hữu ích cho cái việc dự đoán ví dụ
các bạn sử dụng cái mô hình dự đoán
nhộng ngoài trời các bạn có thể thông
tin về độ ẩm lượng mưa thì các bạn có
thể các bạn chèn thêm đây ví dụ không
các bạn muốn dự án nh độ ngoài trời hôm
nay mà các bạn biết thông tin về độ ẩm
các bạn cho vào hoặ lượ Tượng mương kiểu
kiểu như vậy sus này đây người ta gọi là
rượu ngoại lai ngoại lai đây t nó cũng
không phải cái gì xấu đâu. Nó chỉ là
những cái rượu ngoài mà tôi thể tôi cho
thêm vào hiệu bổ sung được chưa? Rượu bổ
sung tôi
cho thêm vào để cho mô hình nó dựa là nó
miễn là cái thông này nó hữu ích miễn là
nó hữu ích mình cho thêm vào đấy.
Được chưa? Đây là cách để chúng ta
convert. Thật ra bây giờ có rất nhiều
thư viện nó sẽ làm cái bước này hộ cho
chúng ta và cả bước chúng ta sẽ mô hình
thấy có rất nhiều thư viện nhưng mà
trong khóa này mình sẽ các bạn cách nó
rất là thủ công để sau này mà các bạn
dùng thư viện các bạn biết là nó làm cái
gì ở bên trong nhá. Chúng ta sẽ học xong
cái phần thực hành chúng mình hãy chỉ
bạn cái thư viện giúp các bạn làm cái
này bây giờ chỉ các bạn chỉn một dòng là
xong thôi. Thế nhưng mà học mà kiểu dùng
thư viện như vậy thì các bạn sẽ không có
hiểu biết được cái phần ở ở bên trong.
Được chưa? Đấy
cái bài án time này người ta dùng
machining cũng được. dùng deing cũng có
cách.
Thế còn với ví dụ như với chúng ta lấy
ví dụ là về NP hoặc là computer vision
chẳng hạn thì thường người ta dùng diing
nhiều hơn người ta ít khi người ta dùng
ta dùng machining tại vì machine nó có
nh rất nhiều cái hạn chế
rồi ok đây chúng ta convert dữ liệu đúng
không thế giả sử đi giả sử chúng ta đã
convert rượu xong rồi được chưa giả sử
chúng ta đã convert rượu xong rồi thì
bước theo chúng ta sẽ chúng ta sẽ sử
dụng mô hình dự đoán thế thì các cái mô
hình về dự đoán cho bài toán time c
forcasting ấy nó có rất rất nhiều format
khác nhau. Có rất nhiều format khác nhau
luôn. Nhưng mà trong đó nó sẽ có hai cái
kiểu mô hình cơ bản. Thật ra chúng ta
chúng ta cũng không có dùng cái mô hình
gì mới đâu. Chúng ta vẫn dùng những cái
mô hình chúng ta học từ đầu đến giờ
thôi. Vẫn là linear reaction, logistic
reaction, support better machine vẫn
dùng những cái mô hình đấy thôi. Chẳng
qua là bây giờ sẽ kết hợp chúng nhau như
thế nào. Kiểu kiểu như vậy. Thế bây giờ
về mặt kiến trúc ấy ta sẽ có hai kiến
trúc chính. Một người ta gọi là
recurship multisep time ccasting. Cái
này người ta tiếng Việt mình gọi là dự
đoán chuỗi thời gian đệ quy đa bước.
Recip là đệ quy.
Các bạn biết thế nào gọi là đệ quy không
các bạn? Thế nào gọi là đệ quy?
Thế nào gọi là hàm đệ quy các bạn nhỉ?
Cái này bạn nào học IT thì biết đúng
không? Các bạn nào học ngành khác thì
chắc là hơi hên xui một chút. Đệ quy tức
là một cái hàm nó gọi đến chính nó đúng
không? Một cái hàm nó tự gọi đến chính
nó thì gọi là hàm đệ quy đúng không?
Chúng ta hay học cái hàm đệ quy về tính
giai tính giai thừa đấy đúng không? N
giai thừa
thì bằng 1 nhân 2 nh 3 nh 4 nh 5 nhân n
đúng không? thì có thể là có thể là n
giai thừa thì bằng n nhân với n - 1 giai
thừa đúng không? Tức là một hàm ví dụ
các bạn có một cái hàm tính giai thừa
thì các bạn lấy cái hàm đấy gọi như
chính nó tham số giảm đi 1 giảm đi 1 thì
đấy gọi là gọi là đúng rồi chuỗi fibonai
cũng thế và bài toán thắp Hà Nội đó đúng
không? Bạn nào các bạn học IT bạn không
sai này gì thôi ngữ đệ quy đúng không?
Mặc dù theo kinh nghiệm mình đi làm, nói
thật với các bạn là mình làm 10 năm nay
mình cũng chưa bao giờ mình dùng đệ quy
trong bài toán thực tế cả. Chưa bao giờ
mình dùng đệ quy trong bài toán tế nhưng
mà khi học về nó rất hay thích lôi bài
toán đệ quy ra đi phỏng vấn cũng thế
nhưng mà đi làm thực sự mình có thể do
cái mảng ai của mình nói nhưng mà thậc
sự mình chưa gặp bài toán nào liên cần
đến dùng đệ quy cả nhưng mà anyway trong
lập trình đây mà toán rất là hay đúng
không? Một hàm tự gọi chính nó.
Thế thì cái cách tiếp cận của đầu tiên
này recursive multistepasting ấ là gì?
là bây giờ ấy tôi muốn dự đoán bao nhiêu
giá trị trong tương lai ấy tôi cũng sẽ
chỉ dùng đúng một mô hình thôi. Tôi dùng
đúng một mô hình thôi. Ví dụ cái mô hình
của tôi đây các bạn nhìn cái hình đây là
mô hình tôi nó sẽ dựng vào bốn giá trị
gần đây nhất thì tôi dự án giá trị tiếp
theo đúng không? Sau tôi sẽ dịch cái cửa
sổ đi một đơn vị đúng không tôi cứ dịch
đi một đơn vị tôi sẽ kết nạp cái ông vừa
rồi thành một cái ông mới. Tôi dư án
tiếp ông ông cộng 2 cộng 3 cộng 4 vân
vân được chưa? Làm cái này thì các bạn
muốn ví dụ các bạn muốn sử dụng cái mô
hình làm sao dựa vào nhiệt độ ngoài trời
của 4 hôm vừa rồi các bạn dự cho 3 hôm
tiếp theo đây đấy đúng kiểu như này này
đúng không thì các bạn chỉ dùng đúng một
mô hình thôi được chưa cái tiếp cận này
có cái ưu điểm là đơn giản dùng đúng một
mô hình cho nhiều giá trị trong tương
lai. Tất nhiên các bạn hiểu này, bài
toán C forcasting ấy nó sẽ luôn có một
cái vấn đề cố hữu là gì? Là càng những
cái giá trị ở xa thì mô hình dự đoán nó
sẽ càng có x cao hơn. Đấy là điều hiển
nhiên, đấy là điều mà khói phải nghĩ đi
đúng không? Các cái thứ mà càng xa trong
tương lai ấy, ví dụ các bạn các bạn các
bạn sử dụng cái mô hình để các bạn sử
dụng các bạn sử dụng một cái mô hình để
để để dưỡng nhiệt độ ngoài trời thì cái
việc mà nhiệt độ ngoài trời của hôm của
ngày mai các bạn dự án tốt hơn so với
của 3 b hôm nữa là chuyện hiển nhiên.
Đấy là chiều mà ông nào cũng gặp. Đấy là
khỏi phải bàn cãi đi. Được chưa? Đấy.
Thế với mô hình này nó cũng thế thôi. T
+ 1 các bạn nó sẽ thường nó sẽ chiến xác
hơn t + 2, t + 3 đúng không? Thế cái mô
hình này cái ư điểm nó là đơn giản. Dù
các bạn muốn dự đoán bao nhiêu giá trị
trong tương lai các bạn cũng sẽ chỉ cần
duy nhất một một giá trị hiện tại thôi.
À xin lỗi các bạn chỉ cần duy nhất một
mô hình thôi. Nhưng cái cận này nó có
cái một cái nhược điểm. Nhược điểm ở đây
là gì các bạn?
Như điểm ở đây làở
đây là gì các bạn?
Cái thện này có nhiều điểm là gì các
bạn?
Ừ thì mình vừa nói rồi đúng không? Cái
việc mà dự án chỗ thời gian ấy cái
chuyện mà cái giá trị càng xa trong
tương lai mình dự án càng x nhiều chuyện
hiển nhiên đúng không? Giống kiểu bây
giờ mình biết ngày dự đoán ngày mai thì
biết gì nó cũng dễ hơn là một tuần nữa
đúng không? Hiển nhiên là như vậy rồi.
Theo các bạn cách tiếp cận này nó có cái
vấn đề gì?
Cái việc mà tôi cứ đúng không? Tôi dự
đoán cái ông t + 1 sau đó tôi ông t + 2
t + 3 kiểu kiểu như này nó sẽ có cái
nhược điểm gì?
Như điểm gì?
Đúng rồi. Chính xác. Tức là cái ông t +
1 t + 2 ấ về mặt bản chất nó không phải
là ground true, nó không phải là dữ liệu
thật đúng không? Cái ông t + 1 t + 2 bản
chất nó cũng là những thứ chúng tôi dự
đoán thôi. Nó cũng phải thật. mà nó đã
ông thật có thể nó sẽ sai mà ghi nó sai
là sẽ dân đến cái ông sau càng sai nhiều
hơn đúng không? Đấy là nhược điểm của
cách thức cạn này.
Cách thứ hai người ta là direct mult
step time casting tức là dự đoán chỗ đề
gian đa bước trực tiếp.
Lá này thì cái thiện nó khác nhau là là
gì? Tức là bây giờ tôi muốn sử dụng cái
mô hình dướ đán bao nhiêu giá trị trong
tương lai thì tôi sẽ cần có từng đấy mô
hình đúng không? Tôi cần có ba mô hình
này đúng không? Ba mô hình này đúng
không? Tôi muốn dự đoán ba giá trị trong
tương lai, tôi cũng sẽ dùng đúng ba mô
hình này. Được chưa? Ba mô hình này. Thế
ưu điểm là input đầu vào luôn là luôn là
giá trị thật. Nhược điểm là tốn mô hình.
Ba mô hình này không nhất thiết phải
giống nhau. Tức là có thể một ông là
linear reation, một ông là support vet
machine, một ông là random forest.
Được chưa?
Rồi
lý thuyết thì như vậy được chưa? Lý
thuyết của bài toán tham gia foring nó
không có nhiều.
Mai chúng ta sẽ thực hành. Mai chúng ta
sẽ thực hành chúng ta sẽ tức là từ đầu
giờ chúng ta có những gì? Chúng ta có
một cái bộ về chúng ta có một bài một
một cái project về cái bộ debit là bộ
bài toán classification nhá. Một project
về score là reaction nhá là hai nhá. À
với NLP là job cái bộ job là 3 nhá. Cái
bộ về em là 4 nhá. Cái bộ này là 5. Được
chưa? Đây sẽ thừng 5 còn 20 phút thì nó
không không đủ để code thì mình sẽ để
mai mình code thể. Hôm nay như vậy sang
tiếp một cái phần mới và phần tiếp theo
nhá. Phần này phần lý thuyết thôi. Trước
khi sang cái phần mới có bạn nào các bạn
có câu hỏi gì về cái phần này nữa không?
Có câu hỏi gì phần này nữa không?
Ư ừ
hỏi thoải mái. Các bạn khác nữa. Có ai
có câu hỏi gì không?
Tiếp nhá. Và bạn cứ gõ đi nhá. Hỏi cứ gõ
mình nói tiếp.
Bây giờ chúng ta sẽ nói thêm một về cái
một cái phần mới. Phần này liên quan đến
liên quan đến đâu ấ nhỉ?
Vọng
nhá. Phần này phần này liên quan cho
chúng ta sẽ nói về các cái lỗi các cái
lỗi trong machining. Đ chưa? Cái lỗi
trong machining. Lỗi là cái gì? Các bạn
hiểu này. Tức là
tức là khi một cái mô hình đúng không?
Chúng ta nói về machine chúng ta nói về
các cái mô hình, các cái kỹ thuật toán
đúng không? Chúng ta hu lên một cái
thuật toán, chúng ta có một cái mô hình.
Thế thì trong machining ấy thì khi mô
hình nó đưa một cái dự đoán tất nhiên dự
đoán này nó có thể đúng có thể sai đúng
không? dự đoán của machine nó có thể
đúng có thể sai. Thế nhìn chung với bài
toán phân loại đi. Bài toán phân loại
thì nó có thể có đúng tuyệt đối và sai
nhưng mà với bài toán regression, bài
toán hồi quy ý thì cái việc đúng tuyệt
đối gần như là không thể. Được chưa?
Trong bài toán re tuyệt đối gần như là
không thể. Thế thì bây giờ [khịt mũi]
cho phải phân tích cái lỗi của nó đúng
không? Phân tích cái lỗi. Thế thì bây
giờ ấy các cái lỗi trong machining ấy nó
sẽ phân ra làm hai loại. Một là
reducible arrows và hai là irreducible
arrow. Reducible arrow là những cái lỗi
có thể giảm được. Còn irreducible er là
những lỗi mà không thể giảm được. Đúng
không? Có những lỗi giảm được và những
cái lỗi không thể giảm được. Đấy.
Thế thì ờ
lỗi không thể giảm được là lỗi gì? Lỗi
không thể giảm được các bạn tưởng tượng
này. Ví dụ các bạn xây dựng một cái mô
hình để dự đoán giá giá
cổ phiếu đi. Giá cổ phiếu là giá giá
chứng khoán hoặc là giá vàng đi, giá
Bitcoin đi. Được chưa? Thế thì kể cả cái
rượu các bạn các bạn có bao nhiêu các
bạn có thông tin đầy đủ đến mức nào? Các
bạn có thông tin về sức bán, sức mua rồi
lượng giao dịch rồi các bạn thông tin về
các cái ví điện tử lớn về quy mô gia thứ
các bạn. Có rất nhiều thông tin về những
gia hàng ngày đúng không? Có rất nhiều
thông tin như vậy. Thế nhưng mà chắc
chắn là nó vẫn sẽ có những cái thông tin
mà các bạn sẽ không thể nào các bạn số
hóa, không thể nào các bạn mô hình hóa
được để cho vào mô hình để nó dự đoán.
Ví dụ cái trường hợp dự án Bitcoin đi.
Làm sao mà các bạn có thể lường trước
được xem là ngày mai liệu ông Elon Mus
ông đấy có lên twit chơi để ông đấy làm
cái dòng treet về giá Bitcoin không đúng
không? Ông nếu mà trt một cái thì kiểu
gì nó cũng có ảnh hưởng đến cái giá đúng
không? Những cái thứ này chúng ta sẽ
không bao giờ chúng ta đưa được vào mô
hình nên là mô hình chúng ta và nó đấy
là một đấy là một cái lý do ngoài ra có
rất nhiều lý do nữa về mặt mô hình có
thể bây giờ mô hình các bạn nó chưa đủ
nó không đủ tốt để nó dự án cho cái bộ
rượu đấy thì nhìn chung là nó sẽ có
những cái lỗi nó sẽ luôn luôn xuất hiện
bất kể các bạn có cố kiểu gì nữa đúng
không và đây những cái lỗi mà các bạn
không kiểm các bạn không có cái nào các
bạn giảm bớt đi tại vì những cái thứ như
kiểu ông ông Elonus ông đấy nói cái gì
làm sao mà các bạn các bạn số hóa các
bạn lường trước được các bạn làm sao các
bạn cho vào mô hình được đúng không nên
là nó sẽ luôn có những cái lỗi mà không
thể giảm được và những cái lỗi này chúng
ta phải chấp nhận thôi cái lỗi này chúng
ta bắt buộc chúng ta phải chấp nhận.
Chúng ta không có cái nào để chúng ta có
thể loại bỏ nó cả. Được chưa? Thế nên
chúng ta sẽ chỉ tập trung vào
Thế nên chúng ta chỉ tập trung vào
reducible er thôi. Thế thì reducible
error ấy trong machining nó sẽ chia ra
rằng là hai loại là bias và variance.
Được chưa? Bias và variance. Các bạn chú
ý là trong machine cái từ bias này nó có
rất nhiều nghĩa khác nhau. Nó rất nhiều
nghĩa khác nhau. Thế bây giờ chúng ta sẽ
nói về nghĩa bias ở đây. Ở đây khi người
ta nói về bias là người ta nói về cái sự
chênh lệch giữ dự đoàn về thực tế đúng
không? Rõ ràng rõ ràng bây giờ tôi muốn
tôi muốn có một cái mô hình mà
có cái lỗi nó bé đúng không? Thì tôi sẽ
cần phải có bios bé. Tại vì sao? Bus ở
đây nó chính là cái size lệch giữa
predictions và actual label đúng không?
Cái bias này nó càng bé thì càng tốt
đúng không? BIOS nó phản ánh cái khả
năng dự đoán chính xác của mô hình. Tại
vì là bias bé thì có nghĩa là mô hình
tốt mà đúng không? Đấy. Bias mà cao có
nghĩa là gì? Bus mà mà cao ấy có nghĩa
là mô hình nó bị đơn giản quá. Mô hình
đơn giản quá các bạn hiểu này. Tức là
các bạn tưởng tượng này. Mô hình nó
giống kiểu là một cái đứa trẻ lớp 5ă
trong khi dữ liệu nó là một cái một cái
đứa à dữ liệu nó là những bài bài tập
cho học sinh lớp 10. Bây giờ rõ ràng các
bạn đưa bài tập cho học sinh lớp 10 mà
cho học sinh lớp 5 nó làm thì là làm sao
nó làm được đúng không? Nó không làm
được đúng không? Nó không làm được thì
có nghĩa gì? Tức là
tức là hàng ngày nó làm bài nó sẽ làm
rất là tồi đúng không? Hàng ngày học làm
rất là tồi và đi thi nó thi nó cũng rất
là tồi luôn đúng không? Hàng ngày đã tồi
thi nó cũng tồi đúng không? Nên các bạn
sẽ sẽ thấy là những cái mô hình mà bị
cái bios nó cao ấy nó sẽ bị một cái vấn
đề tức là bios thì càng bé càng tốt. Tại
vì bios nó phản ánh cái mức độ x lệch dự
đoán như thực tế đúng không? Bus cao có
nghĩa làu tức là tức là gì? Tức là lỗi
nó cao trên cả bộ truyên và cả bộ test.
Bộ truyên lỗi cũng cao, bộ test lỗi cũng
cao. Được chưa? Trên lỗi cao, test lỗi
cũng cao.
Được chưa? Trên lỗi cao, test lỗi cũng
cao. Mô hình nó bị đơn giản quá. Nó bị
đơn giản quá. Và trong maching người ta
gọi nó là underfitting. Fit nghĩa là
khớp. Underfeitting nghĩa là chưa khớp.
Được chưa? Lúc học làm cũng kém, lúc thi
làm cũng kém. Đúng không? Bài tập thì
phức tạp, trong khi mô hình thì đơn
giản. bài tập của học sinh lớp 10 học
sinh mới học đến lớp 5 thôi không làm
được chưa? Đấy là về bias.
Cái gậy thứ hai khi nói về lỗi của mô
hình nó nói về variance. Variance là cái
gì? Các bạn tưởng tượng này, chúng ta
khi mà chúng ta xây dựng và chúng ta
huấn luyện một cái mô hình machining thì
cái mục tiêu của chúng ta ấy không phải
là cái mô hình, nó làm rất là tốt trên
bộ tren không phải như vậy. Cái bộ
truyên ấy suy cho cùng cũng như là cái
thứ mà chúng ta huấn luyện để cho mô
hình nó làm quen với dữ liệu thôi. Cái
mà chúng ta muốn là gì? Là sau này đem
mô hình đi triển khai hoặc là nói một
cách đơn giản chí là chúng ta làm cái bộ
test đấy đúng không? Chúng ta muốn là
lúc đấy cái performance của mình nó là
tốt nhất. Đúng không? Các bạn đi học
ngày xưa cũng thế thôi. Cái mục tiêu của
bạn đi học ngày xưa ấy không phải là
kiếm điểm 10 hàng ngày đúng không? Hàng
ngày điểm 10 thì cũng tốt đấy. Nhưng mà
đấy không phải là cái mục tiêu tối thiệu
của các bạn. Mục tiêu tối thiệu của các
bạn là gì? Là đến lúc mà các bạn đi thi
tốt nghiệp kệp chu phổ thông các bạn
được 10. Đấy mà mục tiêu tối hiệu của
các bạn đúng không? Mà rõ ràng các bạn
nhìn này, rõ ràng ấy là cái bài học hàng
ngày ấ nó sẽ không bao giờ giống y trang
với cái bài thi đúng không? Kiểu bài,
dạng bài có thể giống nhưng mà số liệu
các thứ nó sẽ không giống y chang.
Thì thì
bây giờ khi mà tôi sử dụng cái mô hình
machining và cả này mô hình diping cũng
thế thôi. Mục tiêu của tôi là gì? Là cái
mô hình của tôi ấ nó phải làm sao để nếu
mà sau này khi mà tôi đem cái mô hình đi
test trong thực tế cái dữ liệu đầu vào
của bộ test ấy nó có thể nó khác với bộ
trê một chút nhưng mà cái output đầu ra
nó vẫn phải đúng chứ không phải là bây
giờ lúc các bạn học các bạn được 10 điểm
nhưng mà lúc đi thi người ta chỉ đổi số
liệu thôi các bạn không làm được đúng
không? Thì cái varian nó nói về cái mức
độ thay đổi độ chính xác của dự đoán.
Nếu mà input thay đổi thì tôi muốn là
cái mô hình của tôi là một cái mô hình
tốt ấy là cái mô hình mà input đầu vào
thay đổi một chút nhưng cái mức độ chí
sắc của mô hình nó vẫn phải là không
đổi, nó vẫn phải tốt chứ không phải thay
đổi một tí là nó đã sai luôn đúng không?
Cái điều này nó ch nó cho biết cái khả
năng tổng quát hóa của mô hình. Khả năng
tổng quát hóa có nghĩa gì? Tức là một
cái ông học tốt ấy là cái ông ông ấy học
về tức là khi mà ông ấy học một cái bài
tập ông ấy một cái bài toán hiểu cái bản
chất đúng không? Ví dụ học về đạo hàm
hiểu xem đạo hàm nó ý nghĩa gì, cách làm
như nào chứ không phải là học vẹt đúng
không? học phẹt thì các bạn người ta chỉ
đổi dữ liệu tí là là các bạn là các bạn
đi đúng không? Thì đây nó cũng như vậy.
Thì một cái mô hình chúng ta muốn cái
variance nó thấp tức là gì? Varient thấp
tức là input thay đổi nhưng mà output độ
ra gần như không thay đổi về độ chính
xác. Được chưa? Mô hình mà có variance
cao có nghĩa là gì? Là mô hình nó bị
phức tạp quá hay người ta gọi nó là
overfitting đúng không? Mô hình nó phức
tạp quá tức là gì? Bài toán cho lớp 5
thôi mà các bạn cho ông lớp 10 vào học
đúng không?
Thế thì làm những khi mà hoặc là bạn
hiểu một cái đơn giản đó là học vẹt. Học
vẹt tức là bây giờ đáng nhẽ là tôi phải
học được cái tính chất tổng quát thì bây
tôi lại học rất là cụ thể. Thế thì bây
giờ dữ liệu tôi tôi chỉ tức là lúc học
điểm rất là cao đúng không? Low arrow on
training set lúc học điểm rất cao mà lúc
thi đổi đề bài tí thôi là là toàn đúng
tức là học điểm cao thi điểm thấp. Được
chưa? Đây là về variance
thì một cái mô hình tốt là một cái mô
hình chúng ta muốn là cả bios với cả cả
variant nó đều phải thấp đúng không? Bus
thấp có nghĩa là sinh lệch dự đoán với
thực tế nó b nó bé. Còn variance thấp có
nghĩa gì? Variance thấp có nghĩa là
input tôi có thể thay đổi đội túnh xác
nó không thay đổi. Được chưa? Thế nhưng
trong thực tế chúng ta sẽ không bao giờ
chúng ta gần như chúng ta sẽ không bao
giờ đạt được một cái mô hình mà cả bios
cả variance nó đều thấp.
Thông thường một cái mô hình nếu mà bios
nó thấp thì variance thường nó sẽ cao và
ngược lại. Đầu tiên các bạn nhìn vào cái
các bạn nhìn vào cái hệ trục tọa độ Dec
ở phía bên trái nhá. Trục hoành Ox là
cái độ phức tạp của mô hình đúng không?
Trục tung OY là lỗi của mô hình đó.
Thế bây gi các bạn tưởng tượng này thì
bây giờ có vẻ là lúc ban đầu ấy khi mà
mô hình bạn nó còn đơn giản các bạn nhìn
chúng ta có hai cái đường màu xanh lá
cây là cái đường dành cho bộ trin là cái
đường lỗi dành cho bộ trin và cái đường
màu xanh nước biển là lỗi dành cho
bộ bộ test hoặc là bộ va bộ va là bộ
test đều thế được chưa thế thì có phải
lúc ban đầu được chưa dữ liệu ta nó thì
không đổi đúng không dữ liệu không đổi
lúc ban đầu mô hình nó rất là dữ liệu nó
giống Kiểu cái bài toán thế thôi. Bài
toán tức là bài toán thì kiểu là lúc ban
đầu rượu nó là bài toán dành cho học
sinh lớp 5 đi. Lúc ban đầu mô hình rất
là đơn giản nó với lớp 1 thôi. Thì lúc
mà nó học lớp 1 mô hình nó rất là đơn
giản thì rõ ràng là gì? Hàng ngày học nó
học rất là kém sai rất là nhiều. Khi
cũng sai nhiều đúng không? Thì lúc này
cả cái er trên bộ trin và eros trên bộ
variation nó đều bé cả. À xin ơi nó đều
cao cả. Nó đều cao đúng không? nó đều
cao rất là cao như này. Hai ông nó đều
cao như này. Đấy.
Ờ đúng không? Cả hai ông nó nêu cao.
Thế bây giờ khi mà tôi tăng cái độ phức
tạp của mô hình lên, tôi tăng cái độ
phức tạp của mô hình lên thì bây giờ mô
hình của tôi nó sẽ
càng ngày cả hai cái lỗi này nó đều nó
đều giảm đi. Nhưng nó chỉ một cái ngưỡng
đấy thôi. Đấy mà khi mà cái mùn nó phức
tạp quá rồi ấ thì cái lỗi của bộ trên nó
sẽ tiếp tục nó giảm xuống dố kiểm. Đây
chính là hiện tượng học vẹt đấy đúng
không? Khi mà bạn học nó quá là sâu, tức
là cùng cái bài toán đấy các bạn học một
hai buổi ok. Các bạn học đến buổi thứ 10
đến buổi thứ 20 các bạn sẽ bắt đầu bật
cái chế độ học vẹt học vẹt t các bạn học
rất là cụ thể chi tiết đúng cái rượu đấy
thì các bạn làm được và đổi một tí các
bạn không làm được đúng không? Thì đây
là lúc mà bắt đầu là cái erố của bộ
truyên nó vẫn cứ ra nhưng mà erop của bộ
vai tr nó sẽ tăng lên đúng không? Đây là
cái lúc mà các bạn gặp phải cái trường
hợp là high variance được chưa? Thế thì
cái mà chúng ta muốn ấy là cái mức độ
cân bằng ở giữa. Cân bằng ở giữa
tức là gì? Tức là tôi muốn là tổng hai
cái erố này nó là bé nhất đúng không?
Bias không phải bé nhất, varian cũng
phải bé nhất nhưng tổng chú phải bé
nhất. Thì các bạn nhìn này. Thế bây các
bạn nhìn thấy ở bên phải ấ tôi có mấy
cái hình tròn đồng tâm này. Nó thể hiện
cái gì? Những cái điểm màu đỏ thể hiện
cho dự đoán của dự đoán của mô hình. Còn
cái điểm chính giữa nó nó hiện nó thể
hiện cho cái dự đoán đúng. Được chưa?
Thì bây giờ ấy cái mô hình lý tưởng là
cái mô hình mà bios cũng bios cũng thấp
và vari cũng thấp. Bus thấp nghĩa gì? T
những cái điểm này nó gần điểm chính
giữa. Chính giữa nó là ground nó là
label mà đúng không? Cái điểm này nó
càng gần điểm chính giữa thì mô hình dự
đoán nó
cái dự đoán với cả từ đấy nó càng sát
nhau.
Thế còn là cái mô hình nó có cái value
điển thất tức là gì? Vari thất tức là
các bạn đ các cái mức độ phân tán của
cái dự đoán nó không có lệch nhau nhiều
đúng không? Thì đây là một mô hình rất
là tốt. Hai đều tốt cả. Nhưng mà mô này
thường trong tự nó không tồn tại vì nếu
mà nó tốt cả hai rồi thì chả có gì để
phải làm nữa. Được chưa?
Cái dạng thứ hai là gì? Dạng thứ hai là
mô hình mà bias thấp mà variant nó cao
hoặc là bius cao mà varian thấp.
Được chưa? Đấy nó hay dạng như này thì
có cửa mưa này.
Được chưa?
Thế thì thông thường ấy hai cái dạng này
ấy thì cái nào đang cao tôi sẽ phải cố
kéo nó nó thấp đi được chưa?
Mô hình mà mô hình mà có bios thấp
varian cao thì tôi phải làm sao tôi cố
kéo cái varian nó thấp đi trong khi tôi
giữ cho cái bios nó không bị tăng quá
nhiều và ngược lại bios variant nó cũng
như thế được chưa? Nó c nó cũng như thế.
Thế còn cái trường hợp mà mô hình cả hai
ông đều cao ấy thì không có gì để nói
nữa. Cái mô hình này thì thường chỉ vứt
đi. Chỉ có các bạn chỉ có thử cách xử lý
khác thôi. Các bạn chỉ có xử mô hình
khác thôi chứ còn mô hình mà cả hai cái
nó đều cao thì gần như là không có gì để
cứu chữa cả. Được chưa? Thông nhể trong
thực tế các bạn sẽ hay gặp cái kiểu mô
hình là bius thấp và vari cao hoặc ngược
lại.
Hai ông cùng thấp thì rất là khó để gặp.
Còn hai ông cùng cao thì mô hình thường
là mô hình vứt đi. Được chưa? Trong một
tế các bạn sẽ hay gặp hay gặp kiểu như
vậy. Đấy,
trong khi mà học học về machining hoặc
đi phỏng vấn xin việc ấy nó rất hay có
câu hỏi người ta hay hỏi về hai cái thứ
mà nó đối lập mà nó nghịch với nhau. Ví
dụ người ta hay có cái lỗi câu hỏi là
hỏi về lỗi lại một và lỗi lại hai, hỏi
về prision và recall, hỏi về bias
variant shade of ta hay kiểu người ta
hỏi như vậy. Được chưa? Bias check off
này các thứ này recol này và lỗi lại một
lỗi lại hai rất hay có những câu hỏi
kiểu kiểu như vậy đây nó cũng như thế nó
cũng giống như kiểu là pion rec ấy đúng
không pion rec thì một ông giảm một ông
tăng variant nó cũng như thế một ông
giảm một ông tăng chứ không thể nào mà
hai ông cùng variant của các bạn cũng
không thể nào các bạn giảm cả hai cái
được các bạn cứ giảm này là ông kia nó
sẽ tăng lên lên ngay được chưa tại vì
sao tại vì muốn giảm bius ấy thì phải
tăng cái độ phức tạp của mô hình nhưng
mà tăng độ phức tạp thì sẽ
Ờ tăng độ phức tạp thì sẽ dễ bị
overfitting. Overfitting làm tăng cái
variant đúng không? Muốn giảm bớt thì
phải tăng độ phức tạp của mô hình. Đây
này đúng không? Lúc ban đầu đúng không?
Lúc ban đầu Bus đang cao đúng không? Tôi
muốn tôi muốn tôi muốn giảm bios đi tôi
phải tăng ph độ phức tạp. Tăng độ phức
tạp đây đến lúc mà đin lại tăng lên đúng
không? Nên thường không bao giờ các bạn
tặng các bạn không bao giờ các bạn có
thể giảm được cả hai cái đúng không? Cứ
thường là ông này tăng thì ông kia sẽ
giảm và người ta thường người ta sẽ phải
làm sang người ta tối ưu cái tổng của
hai ông này. Tức là gì? varian cộng với
bình phương. Vì sao lại phải bình
phương? Tại vì varian thường thường nó
tính bằng bậc hai. Trong b là bậc 1 cộng
nó vào nó mới nó mới cùng cái thứ nguyên
nó mới cộng được với nhau. Được chưa?
Thì các bạn sẽ học các bạn rất rất là
hay nghe nghe cái từ overfitting.
Overfitting là cái từ mà các bạn học các
bạn hay nghe thấy rất là nhiều.
Overfitting có nghĩa gì? Tức là mô hình
quá trình huấn luyện thì làm rất là tốt
99 100% mà đem triển khai nó tồi. Các
bạn chú ý nhá. Có một cái yêu điều này
mình thấy rất nhiều người khi ta học về
AI, học về machining ấy, người ta cứ
thấy một cái mô hình có cái quá trình
huấn luyện, một cái mô hình có quá trình
huấn luyện mà có cái accuracy là 99 hoặc
là 100% người ta bảo ngay đây là mô hình
bị ô fiting. Không phải như vậy. Một cái
mô hình nó có cái aquasi của bộ trang là
99 hay là 100% ấy, đấy chỉ là điều kiện
cần của â Fitting thôi. Nó không phải
điều kiện đủ. Điều kiện đủ điều kiện cần
và đủ của ting là gì? là bộ trin
accuracy cũng cao, bộ test accuracy cũng
cao hoặc là bộ va ac cũng cao ấy. Đấy
mới là điều kiện đầy đủ chứ còn chỉ mỗi
bộ trê mà được 100% chưa nói được cái gì
cả. Giống như kiểu ngày xưa các bạn đi
học thế thôi. Hàng ngày các bạn được 10
điểm
không thể bảo đây là học vẹt được. Hàng
ngày được 10 điểm mà đi thi chỉ có một
hai điểm ấy. Lúc đấy mới là học vẹt.
Được chưa?
Rồi. Ok.
Có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Đến đây có nào câu hỏi gì không?
Thế thì các bạn nhìn này. Thế thì khi mà
thật ra ấy cái slide này ấy nó sẽ chỉ
phù hợp với cái thời ngày xưa.
Ờ thời ngày xưa thì thì thì nó phù hợp.
Tại vì thời ngày xưa thưởng dữ liệu nó
không có ờ nhiều cái kỹ thuật nó đơn
giản. Còn th ngày nay cái này thật ra
không phải ngày xưa mà lúc mà các bạn đi
phỏng vấn ấy thì cái này nó cần lúc các
bạn đi làm việc thì nó cũng chả cần lắm.
Tại vì là tại vì lúc mà các bạn đi làm
ấy trong lúc các bạn ngồi nghĩ xem là
dùng kỹ thuật gì các bạn chạy những cái
thư viện như kiểu lazy brick nó đã chạy
xong xứ rồi được chưa? Thì thông thường
ấy khi mà chúng ta
chúng ta mà có những cái bộ dữ liệu mà
có nhiều nhiều data ít feature tức là
gì? Tức là nhiều hàng ít cột được chưa?
Những cái bộ rượu mà có nhiều hàng ít
cột thì chúng ta sẽ nên chọn những cái
mô hình mà nó low bios và high variance.
Được chưa? Nhiều hàng ít cột thì nên
chọn mô hình low bios và high variance.
Thế còn ít hàng nhiều cột thì chúng ta
nên chọn những cái mô hình mà high bias
với low variant đâ tên mô hình đây. Còn
khi mà ví dụ các bạn nhiều hàng nhiều
cột thì thứ nhất là các bạn có thể các
bạn giảm chiều dữ liệu để đưa nó về
trường hợp là nhiều hàng ít cột và hai
là các bạn sử dụng mạng neuron. Các bạn
sử dụng deep learning các bạn sử dụng
mạng neuron. Mạng nonon sẽ rất phù hợp
với những cái dữ liệu phức tạp nhiều
phức tạp và những cái dữ liệu phi cấu
trúc như kiểu NLP text trong NP hoàn về
ảnh bộn vừa rồi đấy. Và những hiệu này
thì thì diping mạng nó sẽ phù hợp rất là
nhiều so với machining. Đấy thì đây là
những cái bước chọn rượu chọn mô hình
dựa vào dữ liệu. Cái này chỉ khi đi
phỏng vấn thôi thì phỏng vấn người ta sẽ
thông thường khi đi phỏng vấn ấy người
ta sẽ đưa cho bạn một cái bộ dữ liệu
người ta có thể người ta bảo các bạn
phân tích phân tích xem là bộ rượu này
các bạn sẽ làm như nào đ các bạn thể
phân tích là ok bộ rượu này tôi có nhiều
hàng thật ra nhá nhiều hàng hay nhiều cố
lên nó phải sử dụng cái thu chột vào cái
sự tương quan giữa chúng chứ không phải
là trên 1000 hàng là nhiều giữa 1000 ít
không phải như vậy nó phải có một cái
tức là nó cái này theo nó cũng không có
một con số cụ thể đâu nó chỉ là dựa vào
cái kinh nghiệm làm việc của chúng ta
thôi các bạn làm việc ở những cái mảng
khác nhau thì nó sẽ có những cái ngưỡng
nhiều ít khác nhau Mình cũng không có
mua con số cụ thể tại vì như mình nói
lần trước rồi, 1000 nó sẽ là nhiều nếu
các bạn chỉ có hai cột. Nhưng nếu các
bạn có 10 cột thì 1000 hàng nó sẽ là ít
đúng không?
Thế
nhá. Đấy và khi bạn đi phỏng vấn người
ta sẽ cho bạn một cái bộ rượu ta hỏi đây
anh phân tích xem bộ rượu này tôi nên
dùng mô hình gì. Lý do là vì sao thì các
bạn sẽ phải phân tích là đây bộ rượu này
tôi sẽ chọn này. Tôi sẽ chọn ví dụ mô
hình tuyến tính tại vì là nó có
coration. Tôi đã chọn mô hình low bios
high variant tại vì nó có nhiều hàng ít
cột vân vân vân. Nhưng lúc các bạn đã
ngồi trong công ty rồi các bạn chỉ đơn
giản các bạn chạy một cái mô hình lazy
predict đúng không? chạy mô hình lck nó
chạy cho các bạn mấy chục mô hình các
bạn xếp sắp xếp xuống th là sao được
chưa
ok đây mới là một bước được chưa còn một
bước nữa một bước nữa thì mai chúng ta
thực hành xong về chắc là trong ngày mai
chúng ta sẽ thực hành xong nguyên cái
time c forcasting chưa xong buổi tiếp
theo chúng ta sẽ nói tiếp về việc chúng
ta sẽ lựa chọn mô hình dựa vào cái
business domain như thế nào mỗi cái
business domain mỗi cái lĩnh vực nó sẽ
có những cái sự ưu tiên khác nhau chúng
ta phải biết xem là với mỗi cái lĩnh vực
chúng ta cần có những cái ưu tiên gì và
chúng ta thể chọn mô hình như thế nào
nhá.
Ok. Có b nào câu hỏi gì không
nhá? Thế mình sẽ đâ hôm nay chúng ta
xong phần lý thuyết về time casting rồi
mai chúng ta sẽ thực hành được chưa?
Mình sẽ app cho bạn code của ngày hôm
nay được chưa? Code bộ NP và bộ camer
vision nhá.
Các bạn biết video này không?
>> [tiếng cười]
>> Tại vì dữ liệu thì khó, mô hình thì kém
đúng không? Dữ liệu thì quá khó, mô hình
thì quá kém anh như này.
Đó
nó đến từ mô hình kém quá thì nhiều hơn.
Mô hình kém nên là cái dự đoán của nó nó
cũng nó cũng phân tán nó không khó hội
tụ được nhá.
À bạn mà có cái có cái câu hỏi về về
cái GDP của Việt Nam nhá. Đúng không các
bạn? Chú các bạn chú ý nhá, với bài toán
time c forcasting ấy không phải là dữ
liệu người ta cho các bạn bao nhiêu các
bạn phải dùng hết. Thì ví dụ như chở của
bạn đúng không? Các bạn thấy là bây giờ
những cái rượu trước 192 nó cũ quá nó
không còn thực tế nữa thì các bạn có thể
bỏ đi đúng không? Nó cũng giống như là
chúng ta làm việc với cái bộ CS:GO ấy
đúng không? Không phải là có bao nhiêu
picture là tôi phải dùng từng đấy. Tôi
xem là cái nào tôi cần tôi hợp lý tôi
dùng chưa?
Ok.
Có nào câu hỏi gì nữa không?
có th m gì được không
thế nhá mai chúng tôi bắt s này các bạn
nhá
nhá mình app các bạn script và mình app
cho các bạn record nhá
có gì c ấn trên zalo các bạn nhá có cái
gì có cái gì mình mình miss trong quá
trình dạy mình chưa có trả lời được các
bạn hoặc có cái gì những buổi trước các
bạn hỏi mà mình quên mình chưa trả lời
các bạn ới mình trên Zalo các bạn nhá
cả ơn mọi người nha
mọi người N